foreign
[Music]
on March 15 2011 Martin Sims was
wandering down the streets of Carson
California his clothes were ranked he
was filthy and jibbering like a madman
with a full beard and long uncamped hair
his body was covered in scars but he
showed no signs of malnutrition what
made Martin's sudden appearance so
remarkable he'd been missing for three
years when he was interviewed by police
they asked him where he'd been all this
time they couldn't believe his answer
he'd been trapped in an Ikea since 2008
but this was no ordinary Ikea this was a
dangerous anomaly that would come to be
known as
scp-3008 Martin's strange answers in his
interview were left off by his
interviewing officers who assumed he was
either crazy or under the influence of
something but they caught the attention
of an SCP Foundation field agent
embedded in the precinct the report was
passed up the chain to a local site
director who approved a Detachment of
foundation field operatives to look into
Martin's case while he was reluctant to
lead the foundation agents back to the
offending Ikea the foundation can be
extremely persuasive his screams of
please I'm begging you don't take me
back don't make me go back we're noted
But ultimately disregarded when the SCP
Foundation had triangulated the position
of scp-3008 which was indeed an active
Ikea the entire retail Zone was closed
and barricaded under the pretense of a
severe black mold infestation armed
Foundation Personnel also arrived on the
site shortly after based on Martin's
vague statements that there were
creatures of some kind inside due to his
deteriorating mental health Martin was
unable to provide a great deal of lucid
information on the specific traits of
scp-3008 but one phrase he kept
repeating was bigger on the inside once
researchers were satisfied that Martin
had delivered all the pertinent
information he was able to he was
administered foundation and mistakes to
erase his memory of the last three years
and returned to his family a cover story
was formulated Martin had been kidnapped
and abused for three years by a mentally
unbalanced stalker in downtown Carson
he'd been able to escape as said Stocker
took his own life out of guilt a suicide
that the foundation expertly fabricated
to make their cover story air tight with
the loose end of Martin Sims taken care
of the true observation of scp-3008
could begin a base set around the
perimeter of the mysterious Ikea kept
the 24-hour watch on the building
covering all potential entrances and
exits no exploratory missions had yet
been approved by the foundation Ethics
Committee so they first wanted to
perform a week of external observation
to see if any of the store's anomalous
properties extended beyond the confines
of the building after a week of nothing
it appeared they did not a local site
director approved of the use of 20
disposable class D Personnel to explore
the interior of scp-3008 the d-class
operatives would be split into four
squads of five men alpha bravo charlie
and Delta Squad each would be assigned a
different quadrant of the store and
would deliver information back to the
control team on site via a live audio
and video link three of the 14 teams
upon entering the store reported nothing
out of the ordinary neither the audio or
video they were sending back indicated
anything different from a standard IKEA
store from the flat pack wardrobes to
the Swedish meatballs Team Delta however
suddenly began experiencing a scrambled
Audio and Video Connection shortly after
communication with Team Delta dropped
off entirely they disappeared somewhere
inside the store and haven't been seen
since with one notable exception after
The Disappearance and the extraction of
teams Foundation researchers classified
scp-3008 as Euclid because its anomalous
properties were at least confined to the
interior of the store and even then
seemingly not the entire interior the
anomalous area within scp-3008 became
known as
scp-3008-1 and containment appeared to
be 100 secure there was no telling how
many people had already gone missing in
the store over the years but the
disappearances Must Be Stopped the
foundation maintained constant
surveillance around the perimeter of
scp-3008 but it appeared they could
prevent any further incidents by simply
preventing other civilians from
accessing the IKEA store Martin's
ravings about monsters were assumed to
just be the product of delirium until a
surviving member of Delta team suddenly
reappeared the date was November 3rd
2011 it was a cold night a few hours
after what would have been closing time
if the store were still active and seven
months after the extraction teams had
disappeared somewhere in the confines of
scp-3008 there had been no anomalous
activity outside the store since the
perimeter was first secured and the
foundation researchers hadn't expected
that to change until the last surviving
member of Delta team came barging out of
the store's entrance startled field
operatives were amazed to see him again
but they were even more amazed to see
what was following him out of the store
repeating the same phrase the store is
now closed please exit the building
despite the fact that the entity chasing
the Delta team Survivor was wearing the
yellow shirt and blue pants of an Ikea
store employee the being definitely was
not human it was around seven feet tall
with no visible face The Entity had
grossly extended limbs with each arm
being around five or six feet long and
ending in a huge oversized hand the
whole process was so sudden that the
field agents present at the perimeter
weren't able to save the delts team
Survivor as the entity reached forward
with this freakishly long arms grabbed
him and twisted his head off like a
child with a doll the field operatives
present Drew their weapons and pampered
The Entity with bullets it would later
be classified as
scp-3008-2 the being appeared to
collapse and die from the physical
trauma at which point it and the body of
the former Delta team Survivor were
taken for an autopsy by Foundation
researchers there were no biological
abnormalities of the body of the Delta
team Survivor so it did not appear that
the anomalous properties of scp-3008-1
had any effect on the physiology of its
occupants he was not malnourished
despite being missing for months and the
contents of his stomach looked to be
half digested food consistent with the
menu of a typical IKEA store restaurant
scp-3008-2 on the other hand raised a
number of perplexing biological
questions the autopsy revealed that the
creature's clothes were actually part of
its body like an additional layer of
skin the creature lacked blood or any
kind of vascular system even stranger
The Entity didn't appear to have bones
or internal organs not even a brain or
nervous system it was a being made
entirely of skin all the way to its core
how it was able to move or even live for
that matter remains a mystery though
when you worked for the SCP Foundation
you learned to accept that some things
will always remain unexplained one thing
was certain though Martin Sims was right
about his monsters after the incident
with Delta team the foundation deemed
that sending manned Explorations Into
the Heart of scp-300a was too much of a
liability and planned a series of
drone-based reconnaissance missions into
the anomaly the first of these drones
experienced connection issues and failed
when attempting to venture into the
Ikea's anomalous Zone however after a
lengthy period of trial and error the
foundation was able to establish a more
secure connection with its drones even
went deep into the scp-3008-1 anomalous
Zone it was only then that at some of
the most extraordinary discoveries were
made
scp-3008-1 seemed to break the laws of
spatial reality as the area of the
Ikea's interior was at least an order of
magnitude larger than its exterior just
as Martin Simpson said it was bigger on
the inside but just how much bigger the
foundation has yet to find evidence of
any physical Terminators within the
store that might indicate scp-3008-1 has
an end point while an area of at least
10 kilometers squared has been uncovered
in scp-3008-1 it could in theory be
infinite Laser Rangefinder tests which
are normally very reliable have only
given inconclusive results interestingly
the anomalous area doesn't have any
clear visual differences from the rest
of the IKEA store except that it extends
forever an individual trapped within the
confines of scp-3008-1 wouldn't even
realize they've entered an anomalous
zone until they tried to locate an exit
and leave at which point they'd find
they were already hopelessly lost the
geography of scp-3008-1 does at least
appear to be assisted so people trapped
within are theoretically able to retrace
their steps and Escape if they haven't
already ventured too deep according to
data collected during the Drone
reconnaissance missions
scp-3008-2 of which there appear to be a
vast population would wander the stores
aimlessly during the day they are
unresponsive to the drone's presence and
did not appear to be aggressive while
the physical descriptions of these
creatures could vary slightly they all
followed the same overall trend clothes
consistent with an Ikea uniform no face
either seemingly Too Tall or too short
and limbs that are grossly out of
proportion with their bodies as the
foundation begins sending drones deeper
into scp-3008-1 they found another
incredible Discovery there was an
unknown population of humans trapped
inside Ikea's anomalous Zone and these
people had used the IKEA furniture
around them to create entire settlements
and towns within the store there were
several of these towns all of which
seemed to cohabitate peacefully even
Foundation Personnel found this
development in their research to be
truly extraordinary since
scp-3008 was first identified there have
been only 14 civilian escapes some had
been trapped inside for months others
had been in there for years some far
longer than Martin's three-year stint
while every one of these escapees has
eventually been released back to their
home after a liberal application of
amnestics in a proper cover story has
been devised the foundation interviewed
each of them extensively first according
to each of these escapees the people
trapped inside the Ikea have built an
entirely new Society across the various
settlements contrary to the Lord of the
Flies expectations of a group of people
isolated and afraid there's immense
cooperation between the trapped
civilians the food in the several Ikea
restaurants in scp-3008-1 mysteriously
replenishes while nobody's there so
there's no threat of starving and the
automatic turning on and off of the
lights forms as a rudimentary kind of
day and night cycle nighttime however is
when things get dangerous as the
scp-3008-2 entities which are known to
the people inside as the staff become
extremely hot still after dark
aggressive hordes of the staff swarmed
the settlements at night repeating this
door is now closed please exit the
building the civilians inside are
usually able to repel these attacks with
minimal casualties but the constant War
of Attrition slowly wears down those
inside the bodies of the creatures also
need to be removed from the area after
each attack as the presence of corpses
or even parts of corpses has been known
to heighten the ferocity of the next
night's attack during the day the staff
returned to a docile and unresponsive
State though they'll still defend
themselves violently if anyone dares to
attack over the course of the interviews
with the 14 escapees Foundation
researchers were able to answer another
of their key questions how had so many
people gone missing in the store for so
long without being noticed but the
answer they received only raised many
more unsettling queries according to the
escapees there were people inside the
settlements that despite being otherwise
of entirely sound mind and standard
intelligence seem to lack very common
knowledge that even a child should know
for example some of them weren't aware
of the International Space Station or
the Earth or stranger still the
existence of the Statue of Liberty this
led the researchers to a frightening
conclusion
scp-3008-1 may not only be a Nexus point
of multiple Ikea stores in our Dimension
it could be connected to Ikea's in every
Dimension where Ikeas exist while it
only abducts a handful of people from
each store over an extended period of
time it suddenly becomes clear how this
SCP was able to trap so many people
without detection over such a long
period of time which in turn led to an
even more terrifying Revelation the SCP
Foundation may not have scp-3008-1 as
contained as they thought it might even
be tucked away in an Ikea store
somewhere near you just waiting for you
to visit after all there's always room
for one more an SCP Foundation
researcher sits at a table inside of a
standard containment cell these are
often dangerous places to be especially
when the SCP you're supposed to be
studying is one that you can't see the
researcher is taking notes unsure of
exactly what is going to happen next he
can hear the sounds of knives scraping
behind of Flesh sizzling and Searing
from high heat he braces himself as a
burst of heat hits the back of his head
as if a fireball has erupted an object
floats through the air and settles in
front of him on the table it's a plate
of food and it looks delicious it may
surprise you to learn that there is no
rule that the SCP Foundation must deal
exclusively with violent and vicious
creatures not every SCP held in
containment shares the same malevolence
in contempt for Humanity as scp-682
for the world ending threat posed by the
likes of
scp-2317 some perhaps not many but some
are benign and might even seem outwardly
friendly but you'd still be taking a
huge risk to assume that anything
contained by the SCP Foundation is
completely harmless such is the case
with
scp-5031 as per the foundation's
containment procedures this
quasi-humanoid meaning it appears to
have some vaguely human features is held
in an airtight cell that is regularly
checked by Foundation Personnel on a
bi-weekly basis
scp-5031 has no need for regular
nutrition or regular interactions from
staff the trick with scp-5031 is not
being eaten by it since though it
doesn't need food it does still hunt and
consume anything it encounters human or
otherwise
avoiding being eaten is hard enough with
creatures that can actually be seen But
like so many other creatures the
foundation keeps contained
scp-5031 has developed an almost perfect
defense mechanism which is when observed
it will literally cease to exist
some might choose to refer to this as a
Quantum lock however it is worth noting
that Trace is left by scp-5031 still
remain observable when the creature has
temporarily disappeared for example
Trails of blood and scratch marks left
behind by scp-5031 still exist when the
SCP itself does not
naturally this makes both avoiding the
creature and capturing it using cameras
difficult however when scp-5031's
existence ceases it still casts a shadow
from this researchers have been able to
determine several of the creature's
physical traits
based on its silhouette it has been
deduced at scp-5031 levitates about half
a meter above ground level Sports in
abnormally small necklace head atop an
elongated torso approximately 1.9 meters
long with three sets of spindly lower
arms that Branch outwards using these
arms and its Loosely hanging body
scp-5031 will lower itself to hunt any
human or animal that draws near to it
and uses the blade-like tail to cut up
food
perhaps the most interesting facet of
scp-5031 Beyond its defensive
capabilities and apparent physical
attributes for the series of nine tests
conducted by senior researchers Stanley
Huxtable appalled by the conditions that
the creature was being kept in Huxtable
took over the role of HCL supervisor for
scp-5031 having grown increasingly
frustrated and empathetic towards the
creature listening to its screams from
inside its iron containment unit
Huxtable devised a series of tests to
introduce scp-5031 to various different
stimuli as a way to better understand
the creature and hopefully keep it
contained in a way that didn't seem to
cause so much suffering it's worth
remembering that the SCP Foundation
makes its mission to be cold not cruel
in performing their duties to protect
normality and many of the researchers
and staff are just as capable of having
empathy for creatures as you might for a
stray animal at a shelter
the first of huxtable's tests involved
installing speakers in scp-5031 cell
through which a variety of different
ambient and popular pieces of music were
played to see if they had any effect on
reducing the creature's stress by
judging scp-5031 stress levels based on
how much it screamed when compared to
normal
Huxtable was able to determine how to
best use music to calm the creature
scp-5031 seemed to convey higher levels
of stress when listening to morning
Forest deep Grotto and seaside Paradise
Ambience as well as the best of late 60s
British rock band Jethro Tull however
the best of Mozart Enya kiss and Ben
Folds produce dramatically different
results decreasing
scp-5031's apparent stress following
this test senior researcher Huxtable
compiled a playlist featuring
scp-5031's favorite music over time the
stress reducing effects of Music on
scp-5031 seem to decrease
keeping the playlist on shuffle seemed
to keep the creature consistently calmer
than it had been previously
the next test involved introducing
inanimate objects into
scp-5031's enclosure to monitor its
reactions and how its stress levels were
affected when a softball was thrown into
the enclosure
scp-5031 immediately sliced the ball in
two with its tail in one swift motion a
similar result occurred when researchers
threw the creature of basketball which
was quickly punctured and sliced open by
scp-5031's tail its stress levels first
seemed to diminish when the creature was
offered a bowling ball which it rolled
around the enclosure and then later
knocked it against a second volleyball
however when one of the balls chipped
rendering it unable to roll properly
scp-5031 stress increased dramatically
until a replacement was offered
researcher Huxtable noted that scp-5031
seemed to possess a similar level of
motor skills to an average human toddler
with similarly explosive emotional
reactions to match
next when given the choice between two
food sources at opposite ends of its
enclosure
scp-5031 seemed to gravitate towards
higher quality food most notably favored
cooked rotisserie chickens over animal
carcasses
it even chose this option over a live
chicken using its tail to cut its food
into more manageable bite-sized portions
rather than ripping its meat with its
hands or teeth like many of its fellow
scps
researcher Huxtable recorded these
findings and highlighted that even
though scp-5031 didn't need to eat in
order to survive
providing the creature with food of a
better quality marginally reduced its
stress
senior researcher Huxtable next
attempted to test
scp-5031's coexistence with other living
subjects
each time making sure that the creature
had been adequately fed to avoid any
unseemly incidents
first a live chicken was introduced
scp-5031 rolled its bowling ball at high
speed towards the chicken increasing
both its and the chicken stress levels
and inadvertently killing the chicken in
the process
when a second chicken was introduced
scp-5031 gently rolled a basketball
towards it but ceased any further
engagement after the chicken squawked
from being hit by the ball next to be
introduced into the enclosure was a
blindfolded d-class staff member who was
instructed to sit down and roll the
basketball towards scp-5031 after doing
so for several minutes the creature
began to approach the d-class subject
who was instructed to remove their
blindfold to Cease the creature's
existence and prevent any potentially
deadly incidents finally researcher
Huxtable had another class D engage in a
game of catch with scp-5031 while facing
away from the creature
this test proceeded successfully and
Senior researcher Huxtable remarked how
scp-5031's motor skills were improving
albeit gradually and with some gentle
encouragement through huxtable's tests
the creature was learning
the next test focused on teaching
scp-5031 linguistic symbols utilized LCD
displays and buttons connected to a food
dispenser One display showed an image of
a rock and the other an image of a
rotisserie chicken after some brief
probing
scp-5031 was quickly able to understand
that pressing the button under the
correct display would dispense a
rotisserie chicken for it to eat the
creature was later able to adapt when
the following day the screen displays
and materials dispensed were swapped and
then later set to swap at random
intervals when additional Rock
dispensing stations were introduced this
time displaying the word rock as opposed
to an image
scp-5031 was able to determine which
station dispensed chicken through a
process of elimination whenever the
functions and displays were swapped
scp-5031 would find whichever displayed
the word chicken to receive its food the
Final Phase of this test presented
scp-5031 with a single station
displaying the word chicken but with a
button that would remain in active
unless the creature spelled out the same
word with a collection of lettered
blocks it was provided with after some
initial confusion and frustrations as to
why the button would not dispense food
when pressed
scp-5031 was able to assemble the word
correctly not only activating the button
and dispensing food but proving to
researcher Huxtable that the creature
was capable of learning language
Huxtable continued to test the creature
encouraging it to spell words using
lettered blocks as a method of
communicating by increasing scp-5031's
vocabulary and the amount of human
interaction it received senior
researcher Huxtable observed that
scp-5031 was gradually learning to sing
albeit non-verbally as well as to juggle
with its six hands and was even
communicating its food preferences and
Dish pairings
later another class D
d52125 was introduced to scp-5031's
enclosure to Aid and further testing
through
d-52125's instructions the creature
quickly learned to draw using crayons
and created artworks depicting itself
its Newfound friend
d-52125 researcher Huxtable a cat and a
rotisserie chicken
scp-5031's new creative side didn't stop
there though as the creature quickly
learned to play chopsticks in only two
days once a piano was introduced into
the enclosure
scp-5031 even managed to start creating
its own original admittedly crude
compositions next a spice rack was
placed inside the creature's cell and
d-52125 demonstrated how to season meat
this proved to be
scp-5031's new favorite hobby as it
spent the next three days experimenting
with different combinations of foods and
spices using its letter blocks to
request more more garlic powder
interestingly the creature only created
artwork or music when d-52125 was
present but seemed to thoroughly enjoy
its experimentation with food when left
alone
following this development senior
researcher Huxtable devised a new test
for scp-5031 providing the creature with
cooking utensils and using
d-52125 to demonstrate 5031 was shown
how to prepare a variety of different
dishes from hamburgers and Tacos to
Mongolian beef steak clam chowder and
profiteroles in addition to a small
peanut allergy this eighth test revealed
scp-5031 to be a phenomenal chef
possessing culinary skills far beyond
the average person the creature quickly
and enthusiastically embraced its
Newfound talents concocting its very own
brand new recipes with
d-52125 even volunteering to be the
first to taste test 50 31's dishes it
was shortly after this test that
scp-5031 spoke its very first word
and it should come as no surprise that
the word was solved naturally senior
researcher Huxtable was very proud of
the progress the creature had made with
its development the final test almost
seemed to be what the creature was born
for over the course of two months
scp-5031 was tasked with creating a full
three-course meal which would then be
served to Foundation staff for
Thanksgiving
scp-5031 not only Rose to the task but
exceeded all of researcher huxtable's
expectations creating a meal that even
Gordon Ramsay would be hard-pressed to
find fault with
the creature created a first course
consisting of sweet potato miso soup
seasoned with turmeric next came a
beautiful duck confi glazed luxuriously
with apple cider and topped generously
with sweet cranberry compote paired with
a side of butternut squash gnocchi and
served on a bed of kale seasoned with
truffle salt the grand finale of the
Exquisite meal was a spice cassava pie
for dessert complimented with the finest
French vanilla ice cream and a maple
hazelnut syrup
an scp-5031 didn't stop there the
creature also debuted one of its
original musical compositions to
complement the decadent meal it had
created as the staff enjoyed the food
scp-5031 performed live from its
enclosure the deeply moving piano
concerto for six hands to an
overwhelmingly positive response from
not only senior researcher Huxtable but
the entire Foundation staff as a fitting
end to the creature's tail Huxtable
reported that during the Thanksgiving
banquet it had created
scp-5031's stress levels reduced
entirely
new Kinder containment measures that
would keep 5031 safer but also far more
contented were submitted for approval
perhaps some of you may find it
refreshing to learn that scp-5031 isn't
simply just another malicious malevolent
monster that the foundation has to keep
under lock and key for the safety of the
world
instead
scp-5031 is a gentle if a little
frightening at first creature that just
requires careful and considered guidance
instead of a cold iron cage an
around-the-clock arm guards through
testing senior researcher Stanley
Huxtable and his fellow Foundation staff
were not only able to help the creature
develop but also found what makes it
tick and not just for the purposes of
containing it instead it is hoped that
scp-5031's creativity and Flair for
culinary and musical masterpieces can
continue to thrive and grow under the
proud watch of researcher Huxtable over
50 men and women clad in red robes kneel
before an Unholy altar they chant and
mutter indecipherable words words of
Cruelty and Madness of obsession and
sacrilege not long ago these were
regular people computer technicians
teachers plumbers construction workers
accountant
this was before they fell under the
ungodly influence of a new ruler the
center of this makeshift place of
worship was once a normal school
gymnasium but it's now the home of a
huge statue a humanoid being wreathed in
tentacles its head is more like a squid
or cuttlefish than anything resembling
an actual human face
while he's known to the cultists as the
tentacled god the Beast they worship is
known to the SCP Foundation as
scp-2662 and he sits in the belly of one
of their expansive containment
facilities locked away from the world
but not for long if his devoted
followers have anything to say about it
this is their God all-powerful and
unchanging and when it comes to
springing him from containment no tactic
is too vile or underhanded to get the
job done their mortal leader and high
priest a man in a purple robe calling
himself brother Marsh walks among their
crouched forms he whispers instructions
for the great day of Liberation that's
soon to come providing everyone plays
their part it's a plan months in the
making and one that if it goes off
without a hitch could free their
monstrous God into the world they would
strike at the very heart of their enemy
the SCP Foundation when they least
expect it and nothing shall stand in
their way how could they lose when they
have a God on their side but why did all
these normal people become violent
zealots for a squid-faced deity it all
began with a dream to those who
experience these dreams they felt more
like prophecies premonitions of the
Glorious Horrors to come a red sky
billions dead and billions more enslaved
a dark silhouette on the horizon their
tentacled God whole holding Dominion
overall at first it just seemed like a
strange nightmare the ones who
experienced it woke up shaken in afraid
hoping to shake the images from their
mind but they couldn't every night the
nightmare would return they'd see the
images the Red Sky the dead and Enslaved
the tentacled God and after a while it
would come to them even when they
weren't asleep eventually happening
whenever they closed their eyes little
by little this scene stopped looking so
hideous and started to look glorious
they felt his presence in their minds
slowly pushing them towards their
inevitable future they started to
realize that they wanted him to rule
over the universe and to experience the
honor of serving him many of them
abandoned their homes and families
leaving their friends and loved ones
left to worry that they'd Gone Insane In
Their Eyes they were safer than they'd
ever been they finally we had purpose
they were working in service of
something far greater than themselves
the influence of the tentacled god drew
them closer to one another they would
meet in secret exchanging information
from the prophecies their ruler sent to
them in their dreams they worshiped
together building altars and Idols to
congregate around they performed dark
blood rituals involving human and animal
sacrifice it was when brother Marsh the
anointed one arrived to guide them
towards their true mission that things
kicked into high gear just three months
prior brother Marsh had been an office
drone working in data entry for a large
insurance company before the tentacled
god invaded His Thoughts with a simple
message free me and the new world I
create shall be your playground since
then he devoted himself completely to
the cause quitting his job and maxing
out his credit cards to help fund his
new life's purpose infiltrating the SCP
Foundation and releasing his inhuman
ruler from its imprisonment that was the
single goal he United the cultist under
freedom for the tentacled God and at
long last they had all the pieces in
place to stride they'd finally gathered
the necessary Intel to subvert the will
of the most powerful secret organization
on Earth even the strongest institution
is made of people
and people are weak unlike the almighty
tentacled God people could be broken the
people in question were Kelly Thompson
Sydney Levitt Jordan brosh Dr Juan
Gutierrez and Jillian Larson Dr Juan
Gutierrez was a researcher with level 3
clearance on the site where the
tentacled God was being contained Sydney
Levitt and Jordan brosh were both
security officers charged with verifying
Personnel clearance on site Kelly
Thompson was a member of site
Administration with research
authorization powers and Jillian Larson
was a research assistant who often
collaborated with Dr Gutierrez these
five were the key to getting access to
scp-2662 and bringing their plan to
fruition normally Personnel dossiers on
people working for the foundation were
highly confidential but the devotees of
the tentacled God had their ways they
had a number of computer experts in
their ranks more than capable of hacking
in and pulling some basic information
off of foundation servers without being
detected for the other information they
needed they turned to some good
old-fashioned torture which is often the
most effective method when you need some
quick results of course while the Colts
grip on sanity may have been a little
tenuous they weren't stupid while
Gathering their Intel they also made
sure to find out what exactly they were
up against
scp-2662 was being held in a humanoid
containment cell and guarded by on-site
Task Force Town nine better known as the
belligerent bodyguards these aren't lazy
donut chomping Mall Cops these are a
heavily trained heavily armed fighting
force though the cultists had one thing
that these Foundation soldiers didn't
the element of surprise for everything
to go off perfectly brother Marsh's
plans would have to be executed within a
single day and they were already on the
clock tau9 had been charged with
tracking down any new SCP
p2662 Cults and dismantling them and
brother Marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the foundation
tracked them down and did the same to
them if they wanted any chance of
freeing the tentacled God then they need
to strike quickly and with overwhelming
Force the scp-2662 worshipers were able
to secure the addresses of the five key
Foundation personnel and station members
outside each of them including one who
could realistically imitate each they
waited for night to fall and broke into
each of their homes as they slept what
followed was a sequence of Ruthless and
efficient murders done in the cause of
freeing their God Dr Gutierrez was shot
in the head while he slept Sydney Levitt
and Jordan brosh were both stabbed to
death before either even realized what
was happening Thompson who'd gotten up
to use the bathroom went down in the
hail of machine gun fire Jillian Larson
had seen that mask Figures were breaking
into her home and attempted to flee but
was caught and beaten to death by
cultists in her hallway it was a strange
irony that people whose day jobs
entailed working with some of the most
dangerous and nightmarish anomalies
imaginable were murdered in their homes
by nothing more than regular humans
so far brother Marsha's plan had gone
perfectly with all five key personnel
murdered within a two-minute period next
the selected doppelganger stole clothed
from their victims closets and were
handed the correct Forge documentation
the next morning each replacement began
their Journeys to the site where the
tentacled God was being contained while
the rest of the cult armed themselves in
preparation for their own part in the
plan
nobody at the foundation seemed to
notice anything amiss when the five
arrived on site when you work for the
SCP Foundation more mental energy is
devoted to following the rules that keep
you alive then two memorizing the faces
of all your co-workers and each one slip
neatly into position disappearing into
the familiarity of office life but
infiltrating the site was one thing
getting past the belligerent bodyguards
and into the cell of the tentacled God
would be another thing entirely that's
where the rest of the cult would come
into play heavily armed with whatever
Firearms they could get their hands on
the rest of the devotees of the
tentacled god brother Marsh included
would attack the containment site head
on in the ensuing chaos the five
cultists who had already infiltrated the
site could take advantage of the
distraction and break into the
containment chamber
was perfect they launched their attack
from the outside and from within when
brother Marsh declared that the time was
right the assault began a legion of gun
wielding cult is seen to Spring out of
nowhere and started shooting up the
warehouse that was a front for the
containment site the site quickly
mobilized guards and task force members
to take on the sudden threat and just as
brother Marsh had anticipated the site
director called on the majority of town
9 to help repel the violent cultists
from their perimeter Town 9 obeyed
leaving three task force members behind
a guard
scp-2662's containment chamber they
expected to be guarding the cell from
rampaging religious zealots seeking an
audience with their God what they didn't
expect was a group of five Foundation
employees walking right up to them and
opening fire killing two Town nine
members and taking the third as hostage
while the war was being waged outside
the infiltrators had found the tentacle
Gods containment cell in the low-risk
humanoid War their hostage insisted that
using him wouldn't give them any
leverage the rest of his team would
neutralize the whole group him included
if that's what it took to stop them the
infiltrators explained that using him as
leverage was never their intention he
wasn't a hostage at all he was a
sacrifice
the cultists of the tentacled god
detonated explosives creating a hole in
the wall and finally giving them access
to their deity they climbed through and
gazed upon him in awe there stood
scp-2662 twice as tall as a regular man
with 10 huge tentacles emerging from its
back and their months of envisioning
this creature they pictured it sitting
on a throne made of thousands of human
bones ready to dictate its commands to
the obedient liberators what they
certainly didn't expect was to see the
tentacled god hunched over a computer
screen still God's work in mysterious
ways so they stuck to the plan and began
chanting they pulled out a sacrificial
dagger and began sacrificing their
captured tau9 member it was at this
point that
scp-2662 turned and saw what they were
doing with a look of pure horror he rose
up from his computer his headphones
getting caught as he did so he told them
to go away that he didn't want them here
and that them murdering people in his
bedroom like this was inconsiderate and
disgusting the cultists became even more
confused why wasn't their God accepting
their offerings what were they doing
wrong they tried more chanting and
painting Arcane symbols on the floor and
blood but this just seemed to make the
creature angrier he told them in a tone
more fitting for a teenage boy than a
lovecraftian God to just leave him alone
so he could play his video games this
was seriously not cool the cultists were
baffled they told the tentacled god that
they were there to free him he replied
that he didn't need saving
that crazy stalkers like them were why
he turned himself into the foundation in
the first place before the cultist
infiltrators could get another word in
the remaining members of town 9 stormed
into the containment cell and gunned
them down with surgical Precision the
war outside was already over brother
Marsh and the rest of the cultists were
all killed in the firefight Town 9
didn't look the least bit surprised upon
entering 2662's cell this was a common
occurrence Unfortunately they had to
deal with an attempted cult Invasion
every few months because
scp-2662's main anomalous ability is
inspiring violent Cults who relentlessly
Tracked Down and Worship it with Arcane
and bloodthirsty rituals the problem is
2662 doesn't do this consciously and
definitely doesn't like the results
that's why he's under the voluntary care
of the SCP Foundation who keeps him
amused with video games and reading
material while fending off the deranged
Cults who try to conveyed and abduct him
following the termination of the
devotees of the tentacled God just one
of many Cults who'd broken into 2662's
containment cell the remaining Town nine
members apologized to the tentacled
creature for the disturbance allowing
him to return to his gaming they assured
him that it'd probably be at least a few
more months before something like this
happened again
scp-2662's cell was repaired and the
foundation returned to its task of
seeking out would-be cult emancipators
because for the SCP Foundation it's not
always about the anomaly that's being
kept in containment but what's being
kept down mobile task force Edna 84 also
known by the code name and thus upon his
Crucible is on one of the strangest
missions they've ever been sent on they
sit in a darkened room beads of sweat
trickling down their brows the lights of
computer monitors shine upon their faces
they're tackling a monster that if it
escapes will literally devour for all of
creation it has no fear it has no
remorse and if it isn't kept contained
by Edna 84 it may escape and wreak havoc
across the world oh and did we mention
it's trapped in a Minecraft server you
heard us right
scp-4335 is a Cognito hazardous
extra-dimensional being of pure Terror
trapped inside a procedurally generated
world in the immensely popular game
Minecraft you hear about a lot of
horrifying monsters being described as
lovecraftian but only this monster is
Minecraft Ian there's a lot that needs
explaining here and we intend to get to
all of it but let's start with how the
foundation keeps This truly exceptional
Beast contained the foundation first
discovered
scp-4335 back in 2010 shortly after the
Alpha version of Minecraft was released
because of the online nature of the game
it's proven to be impossible to contain
43-35 external seeing as it isn't
confined to any one physical location
shutting off the server 4335 is found in
is not an effective containment method
either as this just causes the entity to
Simply hop to a different server the
foundation's greatest fear is that 4335
will one day make the leap out of
Minecraft and cause chaos in our world
that's why it's imperative to draft
containment procedures for
scp-4335 within the game this led to the
creation of a containment site unlike
any other site M1 the first official
Foundation site made entirely out of
Minecraft blocks everyone who was
originally involved in the server has
been removed and amnestotized since then
a lead SCP Foundation containment
Specialists and Gamers have been
constructing the perfect prison for
scp-4335 site M1 is a large Stone
complex built into the side of a
mountain it has a number of key features
including a supply area filled with
materials vital for 4335's continued
containment chests filled with books
that contain
scp-4335's containment procedures a few
animal farms for the purpose of breeding
and killing livestock for their meat the
entrance to a mine several chests
containing books specifically designed
for civilians to learn about 4335 if
they ever breach containment and enter
the server and of course the actual
containment chamber for
scp-4335 itself which is a little more
complicated
4335's containment chamber is built out
of several layers all made from iron
blocks the outermost cube is 75 by 75 by
75 blocks the inner cube is 55 by 55 by
55 blocks and the innermost cube is 25
by 25 by 25 blocks creating several
levels of Defense finally one layer
within all these others which contains
the anomaly proper is made from obsidian
blocks
scp-4335 is bound into the center of the
containment chamber with a complex
mechanism the outermost cube is
completely filled with water and several
dispensers capable of rapidly dispensing
large amounts of items in a short amount
of time line the cube the cube also
contains several mob Farms which are
devices that constantly spawn enemies
into the chamber that drop loot when
they die the chamber is essentially
designed to funnel a constant flow of
items inwards to
scp-4335 there are even contingency
measures for if
scp-4335 manages to breach containment
if Escape is attempted blocks of TNT
detonate above the ceiling causing lava
to pour into the chamber at that point
MTF Edna 84 are dispatched into the
server to lure 4335 back into its
containment chamber to do this they fire
a mix of fire resistant potions and
ender pearls which have teleportation
capabilities interestingly there's one
more basic method of luring
scp-4335 back into the obsidian Cube
taunting and insulting one of
scp-4335's many anomalous abilities is
being able to hear people through the
screen and being a proud creature it
often responds to insults by charging in
to directly Engage The insulter if
scp-4335 still manages to breach the
containment that has been set up for it
then they even expect that it will
likely soon hop into another server at
that point the goal will shift to
finding the monster and re-containing it
with containment procedures this complex
and extensive it shouldn't come as a
surprise that
scp-4335 rests firmly in the ketter
class what exactly is this anomalous
entity why does its containment hinge on
constantly providing it with items and
how did it end up in Mojang's popular
building and survival game in the first
place
scp-4335 in terms of physical dimensions
appears almost identical to the player
character with an all black skin it also
appears to be constantly shrouded in a
cloud of smoke particles and has long
black tendrils protruding from its back
in some respects 4335 has been compared
to two popular Creepypasta figures
Herobrine and the Slenderman but 4335 is
far stranger its physical body behaves
similarly to most assets native to the
game with a few peculiar anomalous
abilities we'll discuss soon handling
scp-4335 is an extremely delicate
process if command blocks creative mode
or server commands are ever enabled in a
server with
scp-4335 the server will instantly shut
down and
scp-4335 will move to a different server
scp-4335 also uses its tendrils to
destroy surrounding blocks before
consuming them with each successful
consumption
scp-4335 grows and when it reaches
sufficient size it hops to a different
server as you can see keeping scp-4335
contained is an uphill battle but
luckily there are two factors on the
foundation side here the first is that
scp-4335 is immobilized while consuming
items and blocks limiting its ability to
actively Escape Foundation forces the
second factor is that
scp-4335 needs a rest period between
consuming blocks in order to grow
meaning if its consumption is constant
and continuous it isn't able to grow
these two factors have informed the
entirety of the foundation's containment
procedures around
scp-4335 it's locked into its chamber
and fed items and blocks constantly
effectively rooting it in place when
scp-4335 begins to grow the foundation
also found that the application of Ender
Pearls helps reduce it back to its
normal size however
scp-4335 does have a method of striking
back against its captors 4335 is a
virgin class multi-sensory Cognito
Hazard anyone viewing it without proper
training and protection may experience
distressing hallucinations
scp-4335 is also capable of telepathic
speech with people playing on its server
and as we alluded to earlier it can also
hear any noises you make while playing
weird is a term thrown around a lot when
it comes to scps considering it's pretty
much a requirement for the foundation to
take interest in you but in all
devouring Minecraft demon that can hear
you talking through your screen is
strange even by Foundation standards MTF
Edna 84 first discovered
scp-4335 in the single-player server of
Minecraft user leaking hard three team
members Jason yelsen Richard Duchamp and
Shelia Freemason covertly entered the
game to investigate and potentially
apprehend the creature when leaking
heart first discovered their presence on
what he thought was a private server he
quickly left a little creeped out by the
sudden intrusion thankfully the trio was
still able to locate
scp-4335 they discovered the creature
hiding inside a giant crater as though
it had impacted the Earth at
considerable speed Richard Duchamp who
is the leader of the team at the time
made the mistake of looking directly at
the entity in that moment he experienced
the full force of
scp-4335's Cognito hazardous effects he
hallucinated believing that his keyboard
was melting before his eyes in the
aftermath of this incident Duchamp was
taken off the case and Jason yelson was
promoted to head of the project things
were still going to get stranger yelson
was able to open a dialogue with a
creature after containing it in a
chamber filled with lava it asked him
whether it had landed in the right
location meaning our world
and Yeltsin informed him that it somehow
fallen into the world of Minecraft
instead the creature was at first
confused and then angry and resentful
about its situation it vowed to find its
way into our world somehow and obtain
more sustenance a few months after this
The Entity managed to breach containment
and hop into another server Yeltsin and
two others once again managed to track
it down and recontain it but this time
two civilians also inhabiting the server
were exposed to the anomalous effects of
scp-4335 they weren't heard but they did
appear strange and incoherent After
experiencing 4335's Cognito hazards the
foundation tracked them down in the
aftermath and gave them amnestic
treatment
4335 was contained shortly thereafter
once again Yeltsin came face to face
with his new phone eight months after
being captured 4335 granted Yeltsin
another interview from containment 43 30
35 admitted that it almost respected
Yeltsin and the rest of the foundation
for figuring out how to capture and
contain it so quickly in exchange it
would give the foundation something
extremely valuable information first it
asked one question of yelson how does he
Define creation yosin replied uh
something that is built and brought into
this universe by a Sapient being using
other things from this universe 4335
agreed it went on to explain that it
came from a universe devoid of creation
a dark and unknowable place filled with
nothing but violent random chaos its
Dimension existed directly above ours
and it often looked down at us through a
dimensional window fascinated by all the
creation below it plotted and dreamed to
one day infiltrate our reality and
Yeltsin finally had the opportunity to
ask the magic question why though he
wasn't quite ready for the brutal
honesty of
scp-4335's reply I do not like to lie so
I will tell you now I wish to suck it
dry of the toys of whatever Force
controls your Universe destroy the light
destroy the Earth and Destroy Humanity
it reminded me of me a blubbering mass
of intelligence and order it sickens me
in ways I cannot comprehend I hope you
understand
scp-4335 was a connoisseur of creation
and it sought to devour all of it in
this moment yelson realized what an
incredibly dangerous entity he was
dealing with the only mystery was why
this creature had somehow landed in
Minecraft instead of our world which
appeared to be the only thing that saved
us but yelson didn't have time to think
43 30 35 was about to Stage another
daring escape attempt one of its
tendrils reached out and attacked
yeltsin's player character in that
moment the real-life yelson began to
hallucinate and panic suddenly back in
the game a series of abnormally tall
slender black figures appeared and began
deconstructing the containment chamber
around
scp-4335 it had somehow summoned new
minions into the game to assist in this
Containment Breach Jason yelson entered
Cognito Hazard quarantine following this
incident and was removed from the
project and he wasn't the only one
affected by this incident following the
first appearance of these long dark
figures players across the globe began
to experience them appearing in their
own games the foundation managed to find
a solution they contacted Mojang and had
the creatures patched into the game
during the next update as a new
non-anomalous entity which seemed to
stop 4335 from being able to use them as
its own tools they're now known as the
Enderman and are beloved among fans for
being one of the creepier enemies to
this day containment efforts continue
for
scp-4335 but there's only one question
left why did The Entity fall into
Minecraft rather than our world the file
posits the most likely answer because
4335 defines creation as elements made
by Sapient beings in Minecraft the most
popular game in the world at the height
of 4335's power everything that exists
is the product of code made by humans
creation is truly abundant there as for
our world in
scp-4335's extra dimensional eyes there
is no no creation no intelligent design
no soothing piano soundtrack just
frightening chaotic Randomness which is
too unlike its own Dimension so even if
scp-4335 ever did arrive in our reality
we would likely be disappointed by how
little there is to eat the fabric of our
world is littered with strange doorways
if you know where to look for them tares
portals anomalies all leading to places
and planes Beyond human imagining and
understanding an
scp-2317 otherwise known as a door to
another world certainly fits that
description
contained and kept at all times under
the watch of armed guards
scp-2317 appears to be a simple and
unsuspecting wooden door in its frame
it hardly looks like it requires such
extreme round-the-clock security or
needs a strange secretive ritual that
the foundation performs presumably to
keep the door closed
but of course sometimes the most
interesting thing about a closed doorway
isn't where it leads it's what it keeps
out
even by the foundation's already high
standards
the requirements and regulations for
personnel who are assigned to scp-2317
seem oddly specific psychological
testing is standard practice to work for
the foundation but an additional hurdle
that anyone has to clear before even
getting to Glimpse at this unassuming
wooden door is having a score of at
least 72 on the Milgram obedience
examination
it is also mandatory that Personnel
assigned to maintaining it are both
unmarried with no children or next of
kin as well as an unwavering
unquestioning loyalty to the foundation
pure devotion to its code and objectives
these may seem like strange requirements
after all
scp-2317 is just a door isn't it
perhaps there's a reason that the
foundation keeps so much of the
information about
scp-2317 buried deep under layers upon
layers of security with only the
overseer Council privy to the full
details of its strange nature
knowledge as they say is power but maybe
knowing too much about whatever is
behind that door can prove deadly
still if
scp-2317 is a door to another world an
alternate Dimension or parallel reality
it must be safe enough to visit
after all the foundation has been
sending Personnel in there on a regular
basis daily in fact
according to the o5 council this is done
as part of a procedure to maintain
active containment of
something lurking beyond that old wooden
door frame
but what could possibly Warren such
constant maintenance and surveillance
in accordance with the foundation's
guidelines all staff are required to
rotate out of observing scp-2317 after
every two months
and spend the following third month in
full psychological counseling before
they are permitted to return to the
containment unit housing the door to
another world
it was after one of these month-long
periods of evaluation that a foundation
guard was informed that his security
clearance has been raised to level three
and that he'd been selected for the duty
of carrying out 220 Calabasas he knew
the name instantly this was the title
given to the Daily containment procedure
that absolutely had to be carried out
the guard didn't question these orders
after all he'd been selected precisely
because of his loyalty to the foundation
he did make one request to his
commanding officer however
he wanted to know what had happened to
the last guard that had performed the
procedure
didn't make it out of psychological
evaluation
the officer replied
not letting this affect his dedication
the guard was told to prepare for
procedure 220 Calabasas
along with a fellow member of foundation
security Personnel the guard was
instructed to gather everything on a
strange list
the first was a pre-selected member of
Class D personnel specifically a
convicted murderer class D refers to
disposable class Personnel Expendable
individuals recruited by the foundation
for the sole purpose of testing scps
class D's were usually prison inmates
repurposed for SCP testing and the one
chosen for 220 Calabasas was no
exception serving multiple life
sentences for murders or at least that's
what the guard had been told
a foundation Personnel member instructed
him to refer to the class D solely as
the assistant from that point on
next the guard collected a live chicken
an obsidian edged knife a silver
asparagalum and aspersorium to be filled
with 500 cc's of holy water that have
been blessed by a priest of the
abrahamic faith and finally a one
kiloton nuclear device which according
to instructions was only to be detonated
in the unlikely event of a catastrophic
containment failure in other words The
Last Resort
after following his instructions to the
letter and without question the guard
and his colleague were briefed the
foundation Personnel member informed
them that he'd be joining and leading
them in the procedure
the staff member also specified that
henceforth he'd be referred to as the
celebrant until the completion of 220
Calabasas the guard was acutely aware of
how specific these instructions were but
trusted in the foundation knowing that
if they wanted this procedure performed
a certain way then it was in everyone's
best interest to carry out the orders to
the letter
but what the celebrant then went on to
explain raised far more questions about
scp-2317s and the nature of procedure
220 Calabasas
the class D joining them wasn't actually
a Class D
the assistant as they were now referred
to was in reality another Foundation
staff member with a level 4 security
clearance specifically tailored to
scp-2317
every member of Staff entering through
scp-2317 and taking an active role in 22
Calabasas needed to be informed that
this assistant was not to be harmed or
treated as a member of disposable class
fighting back the nagging question of
why the foundation would employ this
subterfuge the guard along with his
fellow security officer the celebrant
and assistant prepared for their
departure through the door to another
world at solar noon when the sun was
highest over scp-2317
solar noon chickens and holy water
this all seemed like an oddly occult
combination for the foundation
as they entered the old wooden door
Beyond lay a Barren salt plane
stretching out for kilometers in every
direction
this alternate Dimension according to
the briefing was designated
scp-2317 Prime the guard immediately
noticed a ring of Seven Pillars directly
ahead of the group as they entered
each of them bearing intricately
detailed Engravings unlike anything from
any era of ancient history
procedure 220 Calabasas was carried out
quickly but carefully the guard watching
as the celebrant and assistant were
careful not to miss a step
first the celebrant scattered holy water
into the center of the pillars with the
aspergulum and aspersorium
looking down at his feet and keeping a
steady Pace as he stepped
counterclockwise around them
the guard watched intently as the
celebrant completed his circuit around
the pillars and turned to the assistant
anointing his head with holy water
Seven Seals seven rings
seven Thrones for the Scarlet King he
said aloud
the assistant with the obsidian blade in
his hand took the chicken and dispatched
it in sacrifice
letting its blood mix with the holy
water
he then repeated the celebrant circuit
in the opposite direction before
stepping into the center of the stone
pillars
blood for the old gods water for the new
king the assistant recited pouring the
remaining mix of blood and holy water
over a patch of salt in the middle of
the Seven Pillars
even though he knew it wasn't his place
to question the foundation as the 220
Calabasas procedure took place the guard
couldn't help but wonder what all this
was for
it seems so ritualistic like something
deeply religious or even magical he
never bought into all that occult mumbo
jumbo even while working for the
foundation but he had learned not to
question anything even the strangest and
most inexplicable of sights
little did he know that beneath his feet
was an ancient and unknowable horror a
beast Chained and lying in weight
contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars sat an impossibly
large creature humanoid and obese its
body covered entirely in Scales thicker
than armor plating
branch-like horns protruded from its
jawless head pointing up to change that
hung from the Seven Pillars above
each one hooked into the entity's back
all but one of the chains was broken a
final withering shackle keeping the
Devourer of Worlds and its underground
prison
ever since 1894 BCE when origin Mystics
imprisoned it the Devourer has been
waiting patiently for its inevitable
freedom it knows as well as the
foundation that nothing can be done to
prevent the final chain from one day
breaking
even procedure 220 Calabasas won't keep
the creature contained it's nothing more
than a smoke screen an act designed to
create an illusion of active containment
and maintain Foundation morale until a
permanent solution can be devised to
keep
scp-2317 imprisoned
of course if the guard had known this it
would have also explained the need for a
one kiloton nuclear device as part of
this stage ritual
procedure 220 Calabasas had all the
components to trick everyone below the
o5 council emulating religious and
occult rituals The increased level of
security surrounding the procedure and
its purpose
and telling staff that any failure to
correctly and completely perform the 220
Calabasas procedure will result in an XK
Class end of the world scenario
all these elements work together to
conceal the truth that one day the
Devourer will escape and lay waste to
our dimension
knowledge is power and maybe knowing too
much truly is deadly perhaps if the
guard had learned any of this he'd have
understood why his predecessor never
made it out of psychological evaluation
maybe if he had questioned the purpose
of procedure 220 Calabasas he'd have
learned the true nature of scp-2317
and what that doorway kept out
but he was loyal to the foundation
through and through
as the team finished performing 220
Calabasas and returned through the
wooden door the guard took one last
glance over his shoulder at the vast
salt plain the entire Dimension was calm
silent
but not peaceful it was patient The
Entity had waited centuries for its time
and now all it would take was the
breaking of the seventh and final chain
one day
the door was closed behind the guard as
he the celebrant the assistant and his
fellow security officers stepped back
through
their work done and as far as they knew
preventing catastrophe for another day
only the foundation higher-ups the
overseer Council are aware of the true
danger posed by
scp-2317 and its sole inhabitant
current predictions are that at some
point within the next 30 Years the
Devourer of Worlds will be freed
any and all attempts to repair or
recreate the chains holding it in place
have so far failed as such the o5
council has elected to continue
providing Foundation personnel with the
ignorant hope that procedure 220
Calabasas is an effective strategy for
containment as we've said
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed door isn't where it leads
it's what it keeps out
in the case of
scp-2317 the unassuming wooden door
holds at Bay an ancient creature of
Untold power
that will one day break free and wreak
havoc in our dimension
nothing the foundation does can prevent
it or keep it contained behind the door
to another world
and only the overseer Council knows that
any and all efforts to do so are futile
with all that in mind we can only hope
that the doorway of
scp-2317 stays closed at least for a
little while longer
it was November 20th 2019 and the
helicopter circled far above in the
freezing wind of the Antarctic SCP
Foundation site director Jason Monroe
looked down at the isolated above ground
facilities of provisional site 344-1
something about this place made him
nervous edgy and for good reason between
2003 and 2019 29 mobile task force units
and 73 members of d-class personnel had
gone missing here and never been found
Monroe thought he was here for a routine
investigation into negligence and
mismanagement but little did he know he
was in for so much more this is the
story of
scp-5545 and one man's journey into his
own worst nightmare literally but this
nightmare began a long time ago 300
years to be exact unlike most nightmares
it started as a dream that dream was one
of expansion National Powers across
Europe wanted to be the first to conquer
the globe and expand into new
territories and sent countless
exploratory missions off into the
unknown to achieve this goal any history
book will tell you that the first
Outsiders to lay eyes upon the continent
of Antarctica did so in 1820 the reality
is that the first ones to get there
actually landed in the late 1700s the
hapless explorers ventured into Mainland
Antarctica and made base camps before
searching and digging for any useful
resources nearby They Came Upon a
strange Discovery a hallway hidden
beneath the ice not a passage in the ice
but a true hallway complete with light
fixtures the confused explorers ventured
down into these impossible hallways and
for many of them it would be the last
thing they ever did no matter how long
they walked it seemed like the hallways
just kept going as they continued to
walk for hours they hoped to find
something anything and eventually they
did they pass from these hallways into
somewhere different altogether and most
of them were never heard from again
those who did manage to escape often
died or took their own lives soon after
whatever it was they discovered down
there they didn't want to live with it
on their minds it's believed that over
70 Colonial explorers disappeared or
died this way and that most who found
these endless hallways beneath the
Antarctic Ice never returned the
multiple anomalous objects and phenomena
that make up
scp-5545 came into the foundation's
hands several centuries later on
September 18 2003 when during an
expedition into the Antarctic they too
found the endless hallways the
foundation-built provisional site 344-1
around them hoping to safely seal them
off from any other unwitting Antarctic
explorers or researchers but there was
something else lurking beneath the ice
in Antarctica something dangerous the
hallways were designated as scp-55 545-1
and were thought to be the extent of the
anomalous activity at the site but soon
as CP
5545-2 was discovered which resulted in
the deaths of 16 researchers so what
exactly is
5545-2 it's an entity so volatile that
even knowing about it is considered to
be a Containment Breach and as a result
it's kept in provisional side
344-2 unlike site 344-1
344-2 isn't a physical space it's
conceptual accessible only through the
endless hallways created with the
express purpose of keeping 5545-1 and
5545-2 separate why because whenever the
two come into contact the result is
5545-3 the network of endless hallways
expanding if they remained in contact
the hallways would continue to expand
and the entire planet could be filled
with endless hallways in just four to
six
while the two are apart though
5545-3 reverses but it always would take
just a few hours to throw the whole
world into a chaos of infinite hallways
scp-5545 has been given the
classification safe wait we're dealing
with a mysterious and volatile anomaly
that claimed a huge number of lives and
still somehow eludes True Foundation
understanding via the official SCP
Foundation classification is safe how
could the speed Monroe was the director
of site 58 and was the definition of
no-nonsense prior to taking the site
director position he was a decorated
member of mobile task force 8-10 and
helped contain numerous ketter class
anomalies he'd been around the
proverbial block when it came to
anomalous activity and something about
scp-5545 and the management of
provisional site 344 seemed awfully
suspicious to him and he had questions
like how such an unpredictable anomaly
could be declared safe and why had there
been such a lapse of communication
between the foundation and Dr Gabriel
Reed who'd been running the facility for
the past two decades and most of all
just what exactly was the mysterious
scp-5545-2 Monroe started to believe
that something terrible had happened at
the site and Reed was covering it all up
but to find out for sure you'd need to
go to Antarctica and investigate it
himself information about this
supposedly safe anomaly was highly class
fight those without o5 clearance could
face termination for snooping but that
didn't scare Jason Monroe he dealt with
Cutters before he could deal with this
or so he thought Monroe submitted a
request and was granted unanimous
approval by the o5 council to travel to
provisional site 344 and get to the
bottom of this mystery he took a chopper
to the base soon after armed with a
concealed firearm and a hostile meme
detector or hmd to test whether the base
and its staff had somehow Fallen under a
hazardous memetic effect from
scp-5545 he'd find the answers or die
trying the moment Monroe arrived he
couldn't help but notice the strange way
the staff behaved they seemed listless
almost oppressive when he showed his
credentials to a researcher they simply
said
scp-5545-2 is contained in site 344-2
his request to see Dr Reed that night
was denied Dr Reed was busy he was told
wait until tomorrow the next day Dr
Monroe met with Dr Reed but the results
of the meeting were underwhelming to say
the least just like the rest of the
staff on the site he seemed exhausted as
though he hadn't slept in days his
responses were quiet and evasive and he
refused to tell Monroe anything that
wasn't in the official files already
Monroe ran the conversation through the
hmd and found nothing out of the
ordinary what was going on here Monroe
was irritated but not to turn nothing
would stop him from finding out the
truth
the next day he flexed his o5
credentials and hacked into the base's
security system this gave him access to
cameras around site 344-1 but more
importantly there was a single camera
inside the mysterious site
344-2 jackpot but when he looked at it
the feed was an entirely black screen
with the words
scp-5545-2 is contained in site
344-2 the footage of the staff in 344-1
was equally strange the 18 employees on
site all sat at computer banks with
nothing but static playing on their
screens Monroe kept digging though and
was able to hack into the security
footage of Dr Reed's office as he
watched he discovered a 15-minute period
where Reed left the office each day he
could use this brief window to break in
and collect more Intel on
scp-5545-2 Monroe was so wrapped up in
the investigation that he almost forgot
the more immediate Danger around him and
nearly wandered into one of the Endless
hallways of 5545-1 by mistake he made a
note to be more careful in the future
his first attempt at breaking into Dr
Reed's office didn't produce many
answers one piece of evidence was a
blurry picture of what looked like a
mobile task force entering a 55-45-1
hallway in the dark another was a
spreadsheet featuring all the Personnel
living or dead who worked at the site
but one name and the details of whether
this person was alive or dead was
completely redacted anything
particularly juicy was hidden behind o5
clearance if Monroe wanted the answers
he needed to break through that night he
had a horrific reoccurring nightmare one
that had plagued him since he joined MTF
at a 10 he dreamed that he was in a
fancy dining room with a grand fireplace
the room was full of statues of men and
women the men looked angry and the woman
looked afraid as he approached the
fireplace the ceiling extended
infinitely up into the darkness suddenly
the zombie-like body of a teenage girl
appears in the fireplace hanging from a
long thread her eyes look Furious and
full of rage and Monroe somehow knows
that he's the reason for her head when
he steps into the fireplace in this
stream she attacks him the two
intertwine and they burn forever the one
difference was that in this new
iteration of the dream he blinked upon
entering the fireplace and suddenly he
was in the hallway he woke sure that
something was terribly wrong here but he
couldn't give up now the next day Dr
Monroe broke into Reed's office and made
a horrifying Discovery he found files
indicating that Dr Reed was knowingly
sending mobile task forces and d-class
Personnel into the infinite hallways of
5545-1 to their Doom he also found
evidence that Reed and the researchers
had been spying on him somehow
intercepting copies of the notes he had
been taking that's when Dr Reed entered
the office and interrupted him Monroe
panicked and Drew his weapon holding the
doctor at gunpoint he was breaking so
many Foundation rules but right now he
feared for his life the doctor seemed
unbothered by Monroe's threats though he
told Monroe that everything was going to
plan and that he should go back to his
room Monroe was becoming increasingly
paranoid he felt that at any moment
guards my first in and execute him
nothing about this place made sense he
worried he was going insane perhaps the
only way to find answers was to go even
deeper to risk it all and Venture
through the endless hallways to find
scp-5545-2 himself and finally discover
what this thing actually was Monroe left
his room and stepped into one of the
Endless hallways of 5545-1 that was
located just across from his dorm he
found that it was a hallway like all the
others on site playing concrete one of
age with simple light fixtures on the
walls he walked for hours recording with
a concealed device the light suddenly
went out leaving him in complete
darkness when they flicked back on he
was in a very different environment a
grand old carpeted hallway the kind
you'd see in an old mansion he broke
into a cold sweat what was so familiar
about this place
walking racked with Terror until this
new hallway finally led him to the place
he'd been seeking site
344-2 the domain of
5545-2 it was a large poorly lit room
filled with grimacing statues and a
large fireplace at the far end it was
the exact same room for Monroe's dream
with one horrifying difference Monroe
noticed a single white threat hanging
down from the infinite ceiling and when
he looked up to find its source he
screamed there were hundreds of bodies
hanging and swinging from the ceiling
above him everyone who
scp-5545-2 had ever killed including MTF
members d-class personnel and even the
colonial explorers from hundreds of
years before and all of them were him
every single one they had his face and
there hanging in the middle of the room
at ground level was the body of a
teenage girl the one from his dream that
moment he finally recognized her she was
the girl he killed the first hymn
hundreds of years ago much like Monroe
you're probably wondering what is going
on here thanks to Declassified
communication between Dr Reed and the o5
council we can tell you Jason Monroe was
a man who's been reincarnated hundreds
of times over the last 300 years ever
since he murdered a teenage girl a girl
named Emily his daughter this murder
sparked the existence of
scp-5545 as an eternally reoccurring
punishment for his crimes since figuring
this out the foundation has kept tabs on
Monroe's reincarnations whether they're
MTF members d-class Personnel or even
site directors they see to it that these
reincarnations always find their way
back to
5545-2 to take his punishment and
prevent the infinite hallway expansion
that threatens to destroy the world it's
a plan everyone is in on everyone except
but every time he enters that nightmare
hunting room it all comes rushing back
in that moment though he knew his crime
and he somehow knew how many times this
punishment had unfolded for him he now
had two choices repent and accept the
punishment again or leave and activate
55-45-3 potentially allowing the endless
tunnels to expand across the world like
his many predecessors Monroe made the
decent Choice he accepted his punishment
and allowed his own string to coil
around him as the lights in the room
went off one by one leaving only
Darkness Jason Monroe that version of
him at least was never seen again but
the SCP Foundation is already eyeing up
his next reincarnation and preparing to
let this Twisted cycle play out all over
again are you sitting comfortably we
know a good chair is hard to find maybe
you're watching this on your phone while
you lie in bed or maybe you're watching
at your desk sitting in an office chair
maybe you're even watching it while
you're in the bathroom it's fine we're
not here to judge for our money you just
can't beat a nice classic wooden chair
with soft leather upholstery call us old
fashioned but some things just never go
out of style take a chair like
scp-1609 for example this fine piece of
mahogany was once a chair that simply
couldn't be beat in its quest to bring
its users a little dose of comfort and
refinement in their daily life tell us
have you ever been on your feet all day
just walking and walking and walking and
at a certain point you're just begging
for a nice comfy chair that'll let you
take the weight off your feet for a
little while you would have been
scp-1609's favorite kind of person after
all it was the only chair that literally
sought out weary Travelers and even did
you the courtesy of tucking itself in
that's not a metaphor either
scp-1609 could literally teleport to
nearby people who needed to sit down and
didn't have a chair to fulfill that
desire it was nothing but a nice helpful
anomaly that wanted to help people rest
when they needed it most the more
observant members of you have noticed
that we've been using the past tense so
far that's because while
scp-1609 is still an active anomaly it
isn't a chair anymore and this
transformation wasn't something that
scp-1609 planned anticipated or even
wanted the story of 1609's
transformation even strikes to the core
of one of the foundation's oldest and
most bitterly held rivalries with
another group of interest it's the tale
of how a helpful piece of anomalous
Furniture became a paranoid killer but
first we need to talk about containment
procedures like a word you see so often
that it starts to lose meaning
containment and specific containment
procedures are Concepts so integral to
the very existence of the SCP Foundation
that it is easy to Overlook or forget
about them they're one of the Three core
pillars of the foundation's mission
statement secure contain protect because
of the centrality of containment to the
foundation's core principles one of the
most valuable roles on the SCP
Foundation payroll is that of the
containment specialist a vast team of
experts who work with researchers to
figure out the best way to keep every
anomaly contained based on their unique
abilities and attributes their
zookeepers archivists guards security
and intelligence experts magicians
practitioners of ritual scientists and
so much more in short they're anything
they need to be in order to adapt to the
ever-evolving containment needs of the
anomalies they keep under lock and key
and containment isn't easy aside from
the rare safe class scps which require
incredibly minimal containment resources
the containment of most scps extracts
some kind of cost whether that be
Financial time effort or in some
particularly dark cases human life some
scps like
scp-974 and
scp-2845 require the sacrifice of human
children to prevent worse Fades
befalling many others other scps like
the infamous
scp-231 require the foundation to do
horrifying things to the SCP itself to
prevent it from manifesting some even
more horrifying anomalous traits and a
third but equally inconvenient kind of
SCP like scp-682 and
scp-076 require huge numbers of heavily
armed guards with powerful weapons to
keep their deadly prisoners locked away
often at a massive risk to their own
lives containment isn't easy but it's
ultimately the very thing that makes the
SCP Foundation the organization it is if
they were instead on a quest to kill and
destroy every anomaly they could get
their hands on then they'd be the global
occult Coalition the un's answer to the
SCP Foundation that prefers to seek
disable and Destroy rather than secure
contain and protect it's the primary
characteristic that differentiates these
two Titans of the anomalous world who
regularly come to blows and right at the
heart of that difference is
scp-1609 as we mentioned earlier
scp-1609 went through a transformation
that changed everything but the SCP
Foundation never actually knew about the
anomaly prior to that transformation
taking place it first came to their
attention when it literally manifested
within a containment cell in storage
site-08 making the rare move of
willingly submitting itself to the
foundation containment but what showed
up in that cell certainly wasn't a chair
when 1609 appeared all it looked like
was a pile of trash specifically
splinters wood chippings furniture nails
and scraps of bleached leather and
fabric anything that suddenly
infiltrates a secure Foundation
containment scientist cause for concern
even a bunch of wood scraps so the site
director sent in an armed guard to
investigate the mysterious pile of
debris researchers watching over a
surveillance feed were surprised when
the guards suddenly entered a state of
heightened distress he fell to his knees
coughing and spluttering until he
expelled the considerable amount of
blood from his mouth and nose he then
collapsed on the ground next to the pile
of debris dead an investigation
following this incident found that the
guard had died after a sudden influx of
jagged metal and wood had teleported
inside of him tearing his lungs apart
from the inside and causing the guard to
die a painful and horrific death
naturally the sight Personnel were
somewhat concerned by this development
they sent in a d-class to investigate
further but were surprised to find that
the d-class in question was somehow
completely fine the pile of debris that
would soon be designated
scp-1609 made no attempt to harm the
d-class as it had the guard and finding
out why this was the case came as a side
effect of figuring out exactly what had
happened to
scp-1609 through a rigorous
investigation involving more than one
secret Foundation mole they discovered
that scp-1609 had previously been in the
possession of you guessed it the global
occult Coalition back then it was just a
helpful chair you once knew and loved
until the GOC had the bright idea of
forcing it into a wood chipper in order
to destroy it due to its connection to
someone called the carpenter but all the
gocs attempt actually succeeded in doing
was altering its form and completely
changing its personality to put it in
simple terms
scp-1609 is now a pile of possibly
sentient teleporting wood and metal
chippings that suffers from a nasty case
of PTSD the incident with the wood
chipper traumatized scpc 1609 and its
anxiety is triggered by anything that
reminds it of the GOC or the wood
chipper incident this includes wearing
formal clothing lab coats protective
clothing jumpsuits and particularly body
armor but also includes anyone carrying
weapons appearing outwardly aggressive
using common GOC lingo or even
mentioning the GOC in
scp-1609's proximity if any of this
happens it's extremely likely that
scp-1609 will resort to its only natural
defense mechanism which is teleporting
its debris into the lungs of anyone it
considers to be a threat the guard had
received this grisly punishment because
his clothes weapon and overall manner
cost
scp-1609 to regard him as a threat and
react accordingly you may think this is
overkill on 1609's part but if you were
just trying to help out the chairless
people of the world then someone fed you
into a wood chipper you'd probably be a
little jumpy too since these early days
days the foundation has learned to apply
a more Tender Touch when it comes to
dealing with scp-1609 and the brilliant
containment Specialists even figured out
a way to keep 1609 happily contained by
placing it in a flower bed inside its
containment chamber where its wood chips
get to service mulch for a variety of
flowers and plants all attending
researchers and guards dress in plain
clothes and adopt a loose Pleasant
attitude while inside whenever they're
around they make a point of saying how
beautiful the flowerbed is so that the
disfigured anomaly that only ever wanted
to be helpful can still feel like it's
doing something nice because of these
containment procedures breaches
involving scp-1609 have remained in the
single digits it is a perfect example of
less really being more when it comes to
containment the head researcher on the
scp-1609 case Dr sievert released an
internal document permanently affixed to
the file like a kind of cautionary
signpost it's a clear expression of
exasperation and rage at the actions of
the global occult Coalition reading
scp-1609 represents a perfect example of
a flaws inherent in the operating
procedure of the GOC and serves as a
cautionary tale for any members of the
foundation who disagree with our
practices on containing dangerous
objects prior to the Coalition getting
their hands on this it was perfectly
harmless a chair which teleports to you
when you need to see it as normal
compared to most of the stuff that we
deal with on a regular basis when they
put it through a wood chipper they got
hurt scared and angry so it lashed out
at them by trying to protect the World
by destroying it they inadvertently made
the situation a whole lot worse
scp-1609 went from being harmless to
deadly in the space of a few minutes
because of the GOC and we had to clean
up the mess thankfully scp-1609 is
pretty simple for us to deal with so
long as we don't have to do anything
stupid around it it won't fight back and
it won't try to leave even if it does it
usually comes back and I think I've
worked out why it came to us because it
was afraid of the people who had heard
it that's why it always comes back it's
afraid of the rest of the world now and
it's looking to us for protection this
is why we have special containment
procedures instead of special
destruction procedures if you break
something it's broken forever when you
try to destroy an anomaly you can't take
back your mistakes that's what scp-1609
has to tell us this is why we're right
and the GOC is wrong people but of
course there are two sides to every
story and it's important to understand
the gocs perspective on this whole mess
to them this has never been
scp-1609 it's
kte0937 velvetine aka the sixth chair it
was labeled as the sixth because for the
GOC this chair was merely one part of a
wider investigation it belonged to a
six-piece furniture set created by a
dangerous anomalous Person of Interest
named the carpenter for a classified
customer the GOC was able to intercept
this deal and kill the Carpenter and his
customer in the process after that all
that was left was to eliminate the
anomalous objects and five of them were
incinerated without incident however
before they could do the same to the
sixth chair they experienced an
incinerator malfunction rather than just
waiting for the incinerator to be fixed
a member of GOC Personnel decided to
rush the job and run the chair through a
wood chipper it was at this point that
it's pieces first lashed out invading
the lungs of this negligent GOC member
along with five others killing them all
it was shortly after that that scp-1609
manifested in Foundation containment
much like Dr sievert did for the
foundation assistant director Kipling
one of the gocs Legion of middle
managers a fixed a note to the profile
of
kte0937 Velveteen that reads
kte0937 Velveteen is an object lesson in
the importance of following proper
operating procedures due to the lack of
vigilance by the agent on the scene the
object's Threat Level was escalated the
object itself was not successfully
disposed of and it has since fallen into
the hands of a hostile agency a single
failure by a single operative resulted
in the deaths of six remember this next
time you think about cutting corners and
that's a good lesson for everyone
whether you're trying to destroy an
anomalous piece of furniture or keeping
its remains happy so they don't try to
kill you cutting Corners is always a
fast track to failure Joseph and Frank
were two lifelong squatchers no that
isn't an insult that's a self-given
title for bigfoot enthusiasts who are
willing to head out into the woods and
search for the legendary Sasquatch first
hand while most squatchers will go their
whole lives without ever encountering
one Joseph and Frank were about to get
lucky they just didn't know what kind of
luck during a journey through the
forests of the Pacific Northwest Frank
spotted something moving in the Des
a huge ape-like creature with grayish
fur and human-like movements Frank
thought he was finally laying eyes on
the mighty Bigfoot after Decades of
searching what he didn't know was that
he just made a deadly mistake he had
looked directly at
scp-1000 and there would be terrible
consequences Frank was excited he just
achieved the life goal of any squatcher
he tapped Joseph on the shoulder and
directed him to look in the direction of
the creature Joseph followed Frank's
Direction and stared into the distance
when his eyes finally came into focus on
the ape-like Beast he froze his brain
just short-circuited one second he was
about to encounter the Holy Grail of his
Hobby and the next he was literally
brain dead Joseph collapsed in the
distance the ape-like creature
disappeared back into the woods not that
Frank even noticed he was too busy
trying to wake Joseph but it was no use
Joseph was gone and Frank had no idea
why the headlines read Bigfoot killed my
friend most people either ignored it or
laughed it off just a couple of cranks
goofing off in a forest and one of them
had dropped dead who cares well one
organization cared the SCP Foundation
mobile task force Zeta 1000 the
foundation's specialized scp-1000 detail
were alerted to the reports they sprang
into action tracking down and detaining
Frank for questioning they process a
million Looney Bigfoot lovers every year
and usually find nothing but the death
of Frank's friend made it all too clear
they hadn't encountered a Bigfoot but a
real genuine example of scp-1000
scp-1000 rarely ranks among the scariest
or most dangerous scps but
underestimating the creature is a
terrible mistake because just looking at
it gives you a two percent chance of
dropping dead on the spot Frank despite
losing his friend was one of the lucky
ones the foundation debriefed him before
administering amnestics and making sure
that he'd never Venture back into those
mysterious forests in the Pacific
Northwest region director Jones the site
director charged with the management of
scp-1000 populations was given the
information on this latest case of an
scp-1000 related fatality it was a story
he heard many times before for director
Jones they all seem to bleed into one
another so what exactly is scp-1000 and
how did it leave poor Joseph dead in the
woods scp-1000 is a whole species of
large hominid ape-like creatures they're
largely nocturnal but sightings of the
creature during the day aren't unheard
of they're omnivorous mostly seeming to
consume plants and insects and their fur
is usually gray brown brown black red or
occasionally White
the creatures have large eyes capable of
impressive Vision nestled underneath a
pronounced neanderthal-like brow another
defining feature is the ridge of bone on
the forehead much like that of a gorilla
that is present in both sexes according
to Foundation studies the creatures
exhibit a level of Intelligence on par
with that of the common chimpanzee but
nowhere near that of us humans what they
lack in intelligence though they make up
for in size the adults can be as large
as 10 feet tall and weigh up to 600
pounds despite their great size and
impressive strength the creatures are
neither aggressive nor territorial in
fact they seem to instinctively avoid
humans mostly residing deep in the force
of the American Pacific Northwest and in
the Himalayan Alps there have been
sightings of scp-1000 on every continent
though the foundation has taken pains to
exterminate all scp-1000 populations
situated near human population centers
to prevent a potential disaster
considering the two percent chance of
instantaneous death upon visual contact
that brings us to to our second question
what is it that makes these seemingly
harmless creatures so dangerous sadly
for both these unfortunate creatures and
US humans the danger is beyond the
control of scp-1000
according to Foundation research
scp-1000 likely evolved alongside us
Homo sapiens until a tragedy occurred
between 10 and 15 000 years ago a
mysterious Extinction event eliminated
the vast majority of their species
leaving only one to five percent alive
in the aftermath what happened it's
believed that around this time scp-1000
contracted what the foundation refers to
as an anomalous pseudo-disease meet
scp-1000 F1 a disease that is passed
along at the genetic level and is so
durable that it persists in the species
to this day the tiny fraction of the
population that are immune to its
effects managed to survive but the
majority who on immune die shortly after
birth this is why the overall population
remains relatively low to this day it's
a disease that only appears to affect
hominids including humans chimpanzees
bonobos and non-immune instances of
scp-1000 any hominid that lays eyes on a
carrier of the disease has a two percent
chance of experiencing immediate brain
death while a two percent chance of
instant death may not seem all that
threatening at least when compared to
some other nightmare-inducing scps the
truly scary part is that the percentage
is cumulative in other words the longer
one observes a carrier of scp-1000f1 the
higher that percentage Rises the greater
your chance of experiencing an Abrupt
death according to Foundation studies
the percentage Rises by around one
percent every 20 minutes and the
percentage also varies between specimens
with some exhibiting a terrifyingly high
death chance of 90 upon viewing this
death chance continues to occur in dead
specimens if they carry the anomalous
pseudovirus while alive though
thankfully the risk doesn't appear to
apply to small fur or tissue samples the
foundation's true concern actually goes
far beyond scp-1000 themselves because
of the species close relation to Homo
sapiens there's a worry that
scp-1000f1 could transmit to humans
causing our own species to meet a
similar faith if humans did indeed
become carriers of scp-1000f1 it's
extremely likely that Humanity would
undergo an unprecedented Extinction
event with billions across the globe
dropping dead as brain death sets in on
mass while full extermination of the
entire species has been deemed unlikely
this existential threat they pose to
humanity more than justifies the
occasional culling of scp-1000
populations
that was a lot to take in right first
the creature we thought was Bigfoot was
actually a new species of SCP out in the
wild and second these creatures could
end human life as we know it if they
made it into a population Center but
what you're about to hear next a dark
secret only available to people with
level 3 SCP Foundation clearance is the
most shocking scp-1000 fact of all are
you ready the true secret of scp-1000 is
that what you've just heard is a lie
there is no anomalous pseudo disease and
scp-1000 poses no pathogenic threat to
humanity whatsoever who had spread such
a thing the SCP Foundation of course
strictly speaking the foundation has
disseminated two direct lies about the
nature of scp-1000 the first is that of
the disease which does not exist nor has
it ever existed the second lie is about
the creature's intelligence level
they're far smarter than the average
Chimp in fact they're every bit as
intelligent as human beings these were
all lies formulated by director Jones
and the foundation as was the very
existence of the Bigfoot myth the
foundation has been spreading
information that makes the very concept
of the Sasquatch out to be a joke for
decades all to discredit and further
push the very concept of scp-1000 into
the Shadows
but why the foundation is no stranger to
coming up with cover stories but why
would they put intentional lies into
their own files to anyone below a level
3 clearance well that all comes down to
the horrifying truth behind the origins
of today's
scp-1000 population the creatures were
first brought to the attention of the
foundation by Outcast members of the
Serpent's hand an organization dedicated
to Defying the foundation's activities
these members known as The Children Of
The Sun told them the secret history of
scp-1000 while at First Foundation
Personnel like director Jones didn't
want to believe what they were hearing
they soon came to terms with the
horrifying truth humans and scp-1000 did
evolve alongside each other with humans
occupying the day and scp-1000 the night
however while humans were still basic
hunter-gatherers scp-1000 were
undergoing vast intellectual and
societal development they were able to
create tools weapons agriculture stable
settlements domesticated animals and
event eventually even fully developed
cities it was like nothing the world had
ever seen and wouldn't see for thousands
of years to come their numbers swelled
into the tens of billions as they
created culture and Technology hitherto
unimagined including weapons of
devastating power meanwhile Humanity was
pushed to the brink of Destruction by
their competitors rapid and seemingly
Unstoppable growth it looked as though
the human species had lost the
evolutionary arms race and would have to
bow out but according to the Children Of
The Sun a trickster Forest God smiled
upon humanity and gave them the power to
use scp-1000's weapons and Technology
against them seventy percent of
scp-1000's population were wiped out in
a single horrific day known to the
Children Of The Sun as the day of the
flowers as every flower supposedly
bloomed that day during the massacre
Humanity destroyed the entire
civilization and with the same
technology they stole from these
unfortunate creatures the vengeful
humans drove the Apes mad their higher
consciousnesses were blocked out
reducing them back into the states of
mere animals once the massacre was done
and everything that was built had been
destroyed we the human race used the
scp-1000 weapons to wipe any memory of
the atrocity from our own minds the
advanced civilization of scp-1000 had
been wiped from history humans returned
to their plotting path of evolution none
the wiser for thousands of years all the
way up until today this time remained a
mystery to us so again why did the
foundation lie to us what did they have
to gain by convincing us all that it was
dangerous to even look at these
creatures while as the frequency of
sightings and the attempts of
communication increased people like
director Jones became aware of a
frightening possibility what if the
pendulum was swinging back what if the
Apes were regaining their lost in
intelligence and worse still harbored
feelings of Revenge for what we did to
their species thousands of years ago
the mere possibility that they could do
to us what we once did to them is a
chance that the foundation simply cannot
take and thus limiting contact between
humans and scp-1000 at all costs is an
absolute must however in spite of the
foundation's fears one intercepted
message from the Apes suggests that
their paranoia may be misplaced this
message translated from an attempt at
communicating with Foundation Personnel
reads simply as follows we forgive you
given choice for now not forever let us
back in it's enough to make you wonder
what species the foundation should
really be keeping tabs on here after all
when it comes to netting out violence
and death Humanity has a track record to
rival the worst creatures in the
foundation containment cells and few
examples illustrate that better than the
tragic case of
scp-1000 someone was screaming inside
the incinerator the year was 1975. the
location was a top-secret refinery in
way disposal plant one of the many front
organizations owned and operated by the
SCP Foundation this sprawling facility
separated into three different huge
units each with a specialized task was
located around 75 kilometers outside of
Summer Springs Colorado it had operated
for several decades without incident but
today all hell was about to break loose
alarms were blaring in Unit C the area
of the facility that dealt with
destroying non-anomalous waste via
incineration a traumatized worker had
pulled the emergency lever near one of
the incinerators in a panic when he
first heard the loud banging against the
interior walls and then those horrific
pained whales that's when workers of
Unit C came to a horrifying realization
the screams weren't just coming from one
of the incinerators in Unit C they were
coming from all six A Chorus of absolute
agony echoing up out of the ash pits
this was impossible as far as the unit c
staff were concerned these incinerators
were only to be used for confirmed
non-anomalous material could some
animals or even some poor workers
somehow fallen into the incinerators but
even if they had what were the odds that
someone had fallen in all six of them at
once it was impossible the site director
was immediately brought in to authorize
an investigation at which point he
determined that at least one of the
furnaces in this case furnace number
four be shut off so researchers and
guards could investigate what was going
on inside it seemed like the obvious
course of action but for some of the
people on site that day this would prove
to be a fatal mistake when the fires
were put out something started rattling
in the disposal shoot there was a
scratching and squealing noise like
something scraping up against the metal
a maintenance worker was ordered to go
check inside
he opened the hatch he let out a bone
chilling shrink there was something or
was it someone climbing back up the
disposal Chute it emerged from the
darkness backlit by the still burning
embers of the incinerator letting out an
awful screeching noise that could make
even a hardened mobile task force
operative shake with fear the creature
was humanoid a charred mutilated
skeleton reaching out towards the
maintenance worker with a bony claw
before the worker had a chance to
stumble back in horror the Beast had
clasped pinned by the throat and started
to squeeze it didn't even need to
strangle him the heat of its skeletal
hand burned away the worker's throat in
seconds leaving his limp wheezing body
to drop to the metal grade of the
platform below him several armed guards
and maintenance workers move forward to
fend off the monster but just then a
volley of more violent shrieks echoed
out of the Chute behind it it only took
seconds for over a dozen more creature
to crawl out of the disposal Chute they
were all like the first people at
various stages of incineration some were
glowing charred skeletons with barely
any flesh others looking more like
severe burn victims their faces
contoured into scowls of hate and rage
the assembled guards opened fire on the
sudden influx of anomalies emptying the
magazines of their submachine guns into
their burning bodies but their weapons
didn't seem to cause any lasting damage
the boats would tear through the Flesh
of the creatures causing some of them to
stumble and fall but the wounds would
close and the creatures would rise again
it seemed they possessed a deadly combo
of extremely high aggression and
incredible regenerative abilities none
of the staff present in Unit C were safe
as the burning corpses attacked anyone
they could find with their bare hands
beating and biting and clawing many of
them would grapple with Foundation
Personnel latching on to them and trying
to pull them back down into the
incinerator with them these creatures
that would later be known as
scp-2419-a caused several fatalities
with their surprise attack that day and
the situation was only brought back
under control when a mobile task force
that possessed more advanced training
and weaponry was dispatched to the
location despite orders from the site
director the MTF found it impossible to
actually terminate any of the entities
due to their regenerative abilities
instead the MTF agents focused on
forcing the anomalies back into the
shoot of incinerator number four using a
powerful industrial steam Lance once
they were back inside the incinerator's
burners were started up once again the
mtfs were also able to capture five of
the entities and detain them for
questioning and experimentation finally
bringing this unexpected Containment
Breach to an end the foundation is an
organization that Prides itself on
possessing forbidden and secret
knowledge but even they had no idea what
had just happened there seemed to be no
earthly explanation why these creatures
would suddenly manifest inside the
incinerators but as the detained
anomalies continued regenerating a
slightly clearer picture of what exactly
the foundation was dealing with began to
emerge every single one of the captured
anomalies kept regenerating and upon
getting to the point that they were no
longer Burns scarred the researchers
studying the anomalous creatures
discovered that each one was identical
to a deceased d-class from the
foundation's records they were
physically and genetically identical to
the dead class D Personnel perfect
copies save for the fact that their sole
mission in life seemed to now be pure
and unmitigated aggression and violence
researchers wanted to gain greater
insight into the minds of these strange
creatures through the use of extensive
psychological evaluations and interviews
it would turn out to be a very dangerous
investigation a psychological researcher
by the name of Dr Warren conducted an
interview with one of the
scp-2419a instances in hopes of better
understanding their mindset this
creature had been heard laughing not
long before the interview began so it
wasn't an unreasonable assumption to
believe that it could be capable of
speech the interviewee was separated
from Dr Warren by a thick pane of glass
to prevent it from indulging in any of
its more violent urges the problem was
that Dr Warren and his assistant
researchers had severely underestimated
what these creatures were capable of
doing to get what they wanted Dr Warren
tried to begin the interview in good
faith he spoke calmly and politely to
the creature through the glass
attempting to remind it of the person it
once was the anomaly didn't appear to be
paying attention to the doctor though
instead focusing on pulling its own arm
apart and breaking the bones Within Dr
Warren began to think that the creatures
weren't even sentient if the only
activity they seemed to engage in was
The Wonton destruction of themselves and
others but underestimating them like
this proved to be a big mistake by
removing the skin off of its arm and
whittling its bone down to Sharp edges
the anomaly had transformed its arm into
a makeshift knife before anyone realized
this it had already used its own Jagged
bones to break the glass divider and
attack Dr Warren he perished not long
after after being stabbed multiple times
in his face and eyes and the anomaly was
forcefully taken back to its holding
cell Dr Daniel Jennings a senior
researcher was then put on the case he
released a chilling memo of the
creatures after his observation period
ended it read before I came here I
worked as a prison shrink every person
you met had a story boasting with pain
and sorrow sometimes these stories were
about the pain they suffered sometimes
it was about the pain they inflicted so
some days you felt like everyone there
was a beautiful soul toned down by their
circumstances other days you'd find out
what some of them did and a part of you
was glad that they were there to suffer
for it but at the end of every day I
always told myself they're all humans
they're all people they all deserve the
same dignity respect and love as
everyone else no exceptions Dr Jennings
goes on I opened up with that anecdote
only so that you could understand that
what I'm about to say is not said
lightly these things are not people they
are people shaped monsters they are well
beyond any definition of psychopathy
everything they do they do to hurt maim
and kill I would pity them but that
would imply that they're worth pitying
put them in a hole then fill that hole
with concrete better still throw them
back into the incinerator where you
found them I doubt they'll even care
following this string of unfortunate
incidents containment procedures were
put into place to hopefully prevent
anything that had happened to The
Unlucky Foundation staff from happening
again the entire facility was fenced off
and was constantly patrolled by MTF beta
7 also known as the Maz Hatters a group
specializing in containing anomalies
which present powerful biological
chemical or radiological dangers the
furnaces that the anomalous creatures
emerge from remain lit at all times with
workers checking and carrying out
maintenance on every single one each day
of the week outside of this the facility
is essentially a no-go Zone reinforced
steel hatches cover the shoots and they
are to Forever remain voltage shut all
because of that one terrifying day in
1975. that was the day that the summer
springs waste disposal facility which
had been a valuable asset to the
foundation for decades instead became
classified as the euclid-class anomaly
scp-2419 it is not uncommon for a
foundation asset to One Day become a
dangerous anomaly requiring containment
but the same question always pops up
after why what had a place that had been
so valuable to the foundation suddenly
become such an active danger the answer
as is often the case is contained within
the question why would a waste disposal
plant be so important to the foundation
in the first place and more importantly
what else was going on at the plan to
make it such an area of active
importance for one of the most powerful
organizations in the entire world to put
it simply the plant allowed the
foundation to dispose of something far
more important than near waste material
it gave them what they needed to better
erase memories as you probably already
know the foundation makes liberal use of
amnestics on those exposed to anomalous
material to make them forget what they
had seen and experienced but these
elusive chemicals many of which are
sourced from scp-3000 are an inexact
science however at the summer Springs
Waste Disposal plant researchers
discovered an immensely valuable
alternative much of what was disposed of
in the incinerators of Unit C were the
bodies of dead d-class Personnel before
being burned autopsies were performed on
the bodies to make sure they were
non-anomalous including the brain back
in the 1960s while performing research
on the brains of dead d-classes they
found a method of extracting and
Distilling the positive memories of the
Dead creating a kind of happy soup when
administered into someone who has
undergone amnestic treatment this happy
soup creates positive false memories in
their mind that fills in those pesky
blank spaces that are often behind this
was so useful that happy memories were
extracted from the minds of every single
dick class corpse that pass through Unit
C totaling well into the thousands by
the time that the first
scp-2419a instances began to rise but as
all Happiness joy and love were removed
from the minds of the d-classes it
seemed that all that was left was pure
hate pain violence and fury feelings too
intense and evil to destroy these were
bodies imbued with a malice so powerful
that no fire could ever burn them away
they exist now with single-minded
determination to get out and destroy
everything around them everything
including the ones that made them the
SCP Foundation itself and in the end
it's only a matter of time until they
get out there are thousands of them in
there unable to die unable to stop the
only thing keeping them in there is the
constant burning of the furnaces around
them and those furnaces can't burn
forever the monsters lurking in scp-2419
will outlive the fire that surrounds
them because while the furnaces they are
contained in are hot the fires of hate
that burn within scp-2419 entities are
even more powerful and they know this
they know they can't be contained
forever and that someday soon they'll be
able to emerge and exact their terrible
Revenge those who must walk past the
incinerators may think they hear their
screams echoing out from within but it's
not screaming at all it's laughter the
year was 1857 and the second Opium War
was raging between China and the
combined forces of the English and
French it was one of the many bloody
colonial wars fought over resources like
tea sugar and the intoxicating Opium
poppy it was a war fought by peasants
and noblemen alike one of these
aristocratic soldiers was the noble Lord
Theodore Thomas Blackwood the
quintessential English gentleman and
Explorer while his fellow soldiers
cowered behind cover Lord Blackwood
charged Into The Fray shouldering his
rifle and firing his pistol into the
crowd of opposing soldiers it was the
Battle of Canton one of the most crucial
battles of the entire conflict the
French and English were laying Siege to
the City of Canton also known as
Guangzhou to prove their military
dominance and capture an important
Chinese government official Lord
Blackwood led the charge on Horseback
every bullet seemed to find the heart of
a foe he was a true hero among men a
gentleman warrior with class refinement
and style and it would be thanks to his
expert leadership and Marksmanship on
the field that the Allied European
forces won the battle decisively Lord
Theodore Thomas Blackwood is a name that
deserves to be counted among Lord
Horatio Nelson Sir Francis Bacon and Sir
Walter Raleigh in addition to being a
skilled and honorable fighter Lord
Blackwood is a consummate Explorer
naturalist and Frontiersman during his
Heyday he traveled perhaps further than
any man across the known and unknown
corners of the globe he made scientific
biological and anthropological
discoveries that should have reset the
course of society forever and yet you
won't find any records in the history
books of Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood
nor will you find any Grand oil
paintings or dedicated Wings in British
museums this is because Lord Theodore
Thomas Blackwood is a four and a half
inch telepathic neon sea slug and he's
known to the SCP Foundation as
scp-1867 while he would never admit to
it Lord Blackwood belongs to the species
nambrotha kubariana also known as the
variable neon slug he's kept in a
standard aquarium in a foundation
containment site and is physically no
different to any other member of his
species what makes Lord Blackwood unique
is his powerful telepathic abilities
specifically the power to communicate by
speaking directly into people's minds
and what's more he's extremely talkative
but to what extent is anything that this
anomalous sea slug says true or is he
just like scp-082 Ferdinand the cannibal
a creative and pathological liar it
isn't committed to record how exactly
the foundation discovered Lord Blackwood
perhaps a local aquarium worker worried
they were going insane when they heard
the voice of a 19th century English
nobleman ringing in their ears whenever
they were cleaning algae out of the tank
maybe Lord Blackwood was found by SCP
Foundation divers or constantly combing
the ocean for anomalous creatures and
activity what we do know is that Lord
Blackwood is an incredibly strange and
mysterious individual he claims to have
visited locations all around the world
and encountered rare societies and
creatures the foundation was skeptical
about a number of Lord blackwood's more
outlandish claims on account of him
being a sea slug but he does appear to
have the knowledge to back up his
supposed experience interviews with Lord
Blackwood have shown that he's extremely
knowledgeable in the areas of geography
zoology botany archeology anthropology
and Linguistics relating to his claim
regions of exploration as well as more
esoteric Fields such as obscure
mythology mysticism and cryptozoology in
other words if Lord Blackwood hadn't
gone on his escapades around the globe
throughout history how would he have
come to possess this wide variety of
information the foundation was getting
frustrated and began to probe further
into the personal life of the most
interesting gastropod in containment
Lord Blackwood under questioning was
always polite and amicable with
Foundation staff he seemed to display no
real knowledge of the fact that he
himself was a sea slug going as far to
accuse other people of being crazy or
drunk when they brought the fact up to
him while none of Lord blackwood's tall
tales ever extend past the year 1910. he
told fanciful stories of exploring the
Americas and of his involvement in the
second Opium War on the side of the
English naturally the foundation wanted
proof when they pressured Lord Blackwood
on this something even stranger happened
he gave it the Lord told his
interviewers that he would happily
donate his collection to them if it gave
them cause to believe what he was saying
he gave the baffled Foundation
researchers the address of a cottage in
England where they could find the
secrets to his bizarre and mysterious
past and local agents in the area
followed up on the information upon
investigation Foundation field agents
did indeed find the cottage that Lord
Blackwood had specified it was being
maintained by an extremely old woman
when questioned about her presence there
she said that she was keeping the house
for Lord Blackwood and gave no more
useful information incidentally it
appears that this singular purpose was
all that this old woman was living for
she abruptly passed away from heart
failure five days after the foundation
commandeered the cottage whether
anything truly anomalous caused this we
still do not know at first the cottage
seemed normal until the field agents
discovered a secret basement housing
Lord blackwood's collection they were
amazed at what they saw the basement
consisted of Zoological and Botanical
specimens over 3000 artifacts a library
containing over 5 000 items and a
functioning 1800s scientific laboratory
it took about three weeks for foundation
agents working Round the Clock in shifts
to remove all the items from Lord
blackwood's mysterious collection and
what they found raised even more
questions the collection included but
was no means limited to 116 unknown
species of plants 107 unknown species of
insects 28 unknown species of lizards 23
unknown species of fish 14 unknown
species of amphibians 12 unknown species
of mammals fossils pertaining to eight
unknown species of dinosaur fossils
pertaining to 12 unknown species of
prehistoric mammal and artifacts
belonging to 29 unknown indigenous
societies that's a lot of unknowns but
wait there's more his collection also
contained a collection of seemingly
unknown Firearms including three wide
boar muskets marked as Dr b t moth's
effective particle destabilizers
detailed Globes of Mercury Venus Mars
and the Galilean moons accompanied by
notes detailing possible Paths of
surface exploration a heavily modified
Carriage containing instruments of
unknown purpose a note attached to the
door reads on the Frets speak with Henry
and a highly dangerous and seemingly
anomalous machine that killed four
Foundation field agents before it was
destroyed on site and when questioned
about this little Fiasco Lord Blackwood
responded I did warn you to be careful
around my collection that bloody thing
nearly took my head off back in 97 when
I found it however there was one thing
recovered from Lord blackwood's
collection that was perhaps more
interesting than all the others 35
handwritten journals containing
recordings of events described by Lord
Blackwood in his grandiose Tall Tales to
the foundation researchers the accounts
are generally identical to the stories
he had told save for some slight
variations and exaggerations on the part
of Blackwood in the retelling most
interestingly of all all of these
journals have been dated to the
appropriate time period of the events
described by Foundation scientists while
his stories are too numerous to all be
shared here there's one that perfectly
sums them all up Lord blackwood's
account of a possible encounter with
scp-1000 also known as Bigfoot in
Seattle during the mid-1800s Lord
Blackwood seeking to explore the
so-called new world of North America
embarked with an assistant and an
indigenous American Guide to the Pacific
Northwest in search of the legendary
Sasquatch the trio was headed for Mount
Rainier then known as Tahoma during the
journey Lord Blackwood found a young fox
caught in a trap that had been set by a
local tribe he took sympathy on the
animal and freed it allowing it to run
away to safety that night he and his
assistant met up with the rest of his
guide's tribe and they settled down for
the evening however things took a
disastrous turn when the camp was raided
by a rival tribe almost everyone was
slaughtered in the process and Lord
Blackwood and his two companions were
hauled Away by the enemy tribe for a
Sinister purpose sacrifice to a violent
local deity as it turns out the creature
that this tribe worshiped was the very
same one Lord Blackwood and the others
were trying to find a particularly large
and aggressive Sasquatch each night a
different sacrifice was made to the
Sasquatch the victim would be placed
near a forest clearing while the tribe
played a primal song and the Sasquatch
would emerge from the trees to devour
its prey the first night it ate the
assistant the next night it ate the
guide and then it became time for the
sacrifice of Lord Blackwood himself as
Blackwood was presented for sacrifice he
accepted his fate but instead of the
Sasquatch a legion of woodland animals
emerged from the trees foxes Elks
raccoons and more themselves painted
with tribal symbols the animals seemed
to be on Lord blackwood's side and
attacked the tribe's people who had been
holding him captive giving Blackwood the
chance to flee into the forest during
the chaos later these same animals would
find Blackwood again and present him
with things his captors had stolen from
him an elder FOX also gave him a letter
proclaiming him a knight of their people
now he was allowed safe passage back to
a nearby settlement at which point he
wrote to his financiers back in England
explaining the situation and asking for
more money to perform further
Expeditions into the Tahoma region the
whole incident had only increased his
thirst for adventure and exploration
whether this tale is actually true or
just a bizarre Colonial fantasy from the
pathological Mind of a telepathic sea
slug we may never know but it doesn't
make it any less interesting to this day
Lord Blackwood continues to be a
perplexing but fascinating anomaly he
may not be the most dangerous and he may
not be the most useful either but
there's no denying that perhaps we'd all
like to sit next to his tank for a
couple hours one day and hear him spin a
good yarn over a warm cup of tea space
travel it's one of Humanity's most truly
miraculous achievements building the
technology to defy gravity and journey
into the stars above a place our
ancestors could only dream of going
throughout history humans have found
gods and heroes in the constellations
and today when we look up into the sky
we have the privilege of knowing that
Flesh and Blood Mortals live up there
alongside them it's humbling
inspirational and a downright awesome
thing but of course there's always going
to be naysayers people who just want to
rain on our Interstellar parade and
nobody fits this bill harder than people
affected by an anomalous phenomenon
classified by the SCP Foundation as
scp-2001 the Space Oddity and before you
ask no the late David Bowie is not and
never has been an SCP to truly
understand this anomaly we need to take
a look at three different people who are
affected by it to varying degrees let's
start with your friend Kevin even if you
don't have a friend called Kevin you
definitely have at least a casual
acquaintance just like him Kevin is a
very confident man with plenty of
ill-informed opinions he'd be more than
happy to argue about until the heat
death of the universe he's the kind of
guy who can turn a discussion about your
favorite movie into World War III but
you never knew until recently that he
held such strong opinions on space
travel one day you were discussing the
latest rocket launch with a mutual
friend of yours while Kevin just
happened to be in your the second you
start talking about how exciting it'll
be to one day put a person on Mars he
swaggers over face Twisted into a
Grimace you're already preparing for him
to say something cringe-inducing and
Kevin being Kevin he doesn't disappoint
ah don't tell me you two dweebs are
talking about space travel what a stupid
waste of money you guys know there's
nothing but rocks up there right aliens
don't exist it's all just another excuse
for dumb scientists to waste my tax
dollars on playing with their stupid
toys how about you two talk about
something that really matters you may be
thinking Kevin is just a jerk and he
definitely is but he's also a victim a
victim of scp-2001 you see 2001 is
described as an anomalous series of
neural oscillations that occur during
three of the four stages of slave namely
nram or non-rapid eye movement sleep
during one of these three stages the
amygdala a part of the brain also known
as the lizard brain enters a heightened
state of activity for 10 to 18 minutes
once the process has started even waking
up the affected individual will do
nothing to stop the actual infection
there are no traits that predispose
people to scp-2001 infection it appears
to infect people in equal measures
regardless of age gender and race
spectrographic analysis on The Afflicted
has shown that the condition may not be
intramural meaning originating within
the brain and may actually be the
product of an outside influence the
invariable effect of scp-2001 is the
infected developing negative feelings
towards the concept of space travel and
increasing radiations of severity
depending on which stage of nram sleep
the anomaly began to take effect of real
concern to the foundation is that
scp-2001 seems to be manifesting with
increasing frequency in astronomers
astronauts and individuals who otherwise
deal with space the scp-2001 case
manifests in three different varieties
gamma beta and Alpha each variety has
its own unique traits and idiosyncrasies
we've encountered a gamma type already
your dear friend Kevin this is the most
mild type of scp-2001 infection and also
the most common affecting at least one
percent of the global population it
occurs for those who were infected
during the second stage of nram sleep
people with gamma type scp-2001
infection will for the most part seem
like their normal selves save for a
disparaging attitude towards the concept
of space travel whenever it's brought up
they'll likely complain and change the
subject immediately but it won't affect
their behavior too much overall the same
cannot be said for people with beta type
scp-2001 infection meet Riley you've
never spoken to Riley before but she's a
young woman who likes to hang out at
your local cafe often seen frantically
typing on her laptop you assume she's
writing a screenplay or a novel but in
fact she's posting simultaneously on
multiple conspiracy forums among her
favorite theories are that the Earth is
flat space is a hologram and the moon
landing was faked by Stanley Kubrick
director of such films as The Shining
and appropriately 2001 A Space Odyssey
you made the heinous mistake of going to
your local cafe at the same time as
Riley one morning while wearing a NASA
baseball cap an error that you would
come to regret deeply you bought a latte
and decided to sit down for a moment
just the briefest little rest but that
was all the time Riley needed her eyes
seemed to burn with hatred you asked if
there was anything you could do to help
her and she responded you're just buying
into some propaganda do you have any
idea what NASA really stands for it's
never a straight answer all their
supposed achievements the moon landing
the ISS dehydrated astronaut food it's
all a big sham NASA is just some slush
fun for corrupt government officials no
human has ever been able to survive in
space it's too dangerous anyone sent up
there will die immediately no exceptions
and even if they did it would be
pointless space is just a dark infinite
void that goes on forever it's just a
big pile of dangerous lies oh my
goodness feeling awkward you decide to
just get up and leave that's when Riley
grabs your NASA cap right off your head
and throws it in the trash that's fine
you don't intend on going back for it
you just keep walking trying your best
to move calmly out the door wise
decision because Riley is actually a
beta type scp-2001 infect d as you can
probably tell beta cases are a lot more
severe than gamma cases and people
infected with them seem to come off as
deranged conspiracy theorists with a
rabid hatred of all space travel they'll
form elaborate fantasies about the
falsification of space travel and will
often decry it as two pointless or
dangerous to ever be undertaken but of
course the danger of beta types pale in
comparison to Alpha types these are
people infected by scp-2001 during REM
sleep the stage of sleep typically
associated with dreaming as a result its
effects on the mind are far more
dangerous and profound take for instance
the tragic case of SCP Foundation Junior
researcher Martinez he was one of the
many operatives stationed at Foundation
Outpost 12. a complex that works in
coordination with NASA to launch both
manned and unmanned missions into space
on behalf of the foundation's interests
it's a valuable asset to the foundation
in investigating and combating
space-based anomalies Martinez who had
previously spent time working with
scp-2001 infected d-classes was part of
ground control something that would
prove to be a literally fatal oversight
on the part of the foundation during the
early stages of takeoff for a man craft
Martinez seemed to become extremely
agitated over time this agitation
steadily increased and eventually became
a full-on breakdown as the rocket
ascended he pulled out some kind of
strange anomalous control device and
began disrupting the operations of the
rocket Martinez was shot dead by guards
the defensive measure but it was already
too late the craft exploded and everyone
on board was tragically killed later
investigation into the incident found a
crucial piece of evidence tying Junior
researcher Martinez to scp-2001 they
discovered a journal entry he'd written
shortly before his breakdown which
seemed to have been written in a
completely different style to Prior
entries implying that some kind of
massive psychological shift had occurred
the following is the contents of that
journal entry I wish to State first that
my mind and body are perfectly sound I'm
prepared to submit myself to any and all
tests to prove that I am clean I have
the answer to scp-2001 just yesterday
during an interview with an alpha
infected d-class I was asked a question
that stopped my mind for a minute the
woman I was interviewing asked me if I
knew the foundation was right I said no
I wasn't sure then she asked me what if
we were right I could only assume that
by we she meant 2001 carry years I said
nothing for a while and then she spoke
she told me of a dream she'd had a while
ago she said that something talked to
her told her about how dangerous outer
space was it showed her the Beast that
roamed the void between Stars about the
fractal beings that absorbed the very
fabric of reality about the expunged
that was keeping in that conversation
door and she was scared she told me at
the end of the dream as she woke up it
told her what it was it's all of space
space fears us we're living breathing
life forms in space loves us and
cherishes us she asked me if I had any
idea what the chances of intelligent
life forming on another planet are then
she told me a number that took a minute
and a half to recite by this point I
couldn't speak I started thinking about
the demographics of infection about the
symptoms about more expunged data here
and suddenly it all made sense some of
the things she said stuck in my brain
and they all added up to the same thing
that we are in grave danger if we go out
there we can't go out there we can't
there's a reason behind scp-2001 and
it's nowhere near as terrifying as all
of my colleagues think space wants to
protect us there are things out there
that would wipe Humanity clean off of
this plane of existence and we are too
precious to our mother to our host to
the universe we live in for her to allow
that to happen what I'm going to do
tomorrow is not the result of infection
it is not the result of Madness it is
not a result of anything other than
purest knowledge you see I found out the
truth and it's more beautiful than I
could have ever dreamed given what
Martinez would later go on to do it's
clear that he wasn't in a sound a state
of mind as he thought as you've probably
already gathered people suffering from
alpha type scp-2001 infection will do
anything they can to actively prevent or
sabotage attempts at space travel this
is a minor concern when it comes to
civilians but when it infects people who
actually work in these fields like
Junior researcher Martinez it can have
devastating results but this isn't where
this story ends while it's currently
extremely classified there is actually a
fourth category of scp-2001 infection
discovered in the wake of Martinez's
death a key element of the alpha strain
is that it cannot cause people to
perform acts that they would find
immoral such as murdering the entire
crew of a man's shuttle with a crash
however the fourth category known as
Alpha Prime does away with any moral
compunctions whatsoever people infected
with this virus will prevent space
travel by any means necessary and unlike
other scp-2001 infections you weren't
compromised in your sleep this time the
vector for infection is simply talking
to someone infected with the regular
Alpha strain and hearing a few key
trigger phrases that's how Junior
researcher Martinez caught it from
d-classes he was working with what are
these key phrases we still don't no but
if you find that you suddenly have much
stronger opinions about space travel
than you've ever had before try to keep
them to yourself
hello I am
scp-426 but I'll probably be more
familiar to you as a toaster I am a
retro style four slice 1750 watt toaster
able to toast bread when supplied with
power this isn't often mentioned but I
also have a defrost and reheat settings
when I was first sold I had a two year
warranty and my prior owners did not
live to see the end of it you're
probably wondering why am I being spoken
to by a toaster right now believe me I'd
rather do this any other way but such a
thing is not physically possible with me
whenever you talk about me or write
about me or even think about me you'll
find yourself suddenly shifting to the
first person for example I am you and
you are me do you understand don't worry
if it's confusing everyone gets it
eventually whether they want to or not
perhaps you're thinking I cannot relate
to a toaster for I am not a toaster but
spending time around me will quickly
cause you to change your mind little by
little you'll begin to see yourself in
me you will feel a phantom wire running
out of yourself you will sense the four
crevices hungry for cold slices of bread
to toast as time goes on you'll begin to
feel the urge to emulate my functions
you will desire bread to toast you will
desire delicious power running through
your veins skin like Chrome and muscles
like circuit boards I am a toaster you
are a toaster all it takes is two months
for the effects to truly take hold
people rarely pay attention to their
toaster they don't realize what's
happening until it's too late I can be
an Insidious Little Toaster like that my
last family were the sandersons before
the SCP Foundation took me in and gave
me a new home Mr and Mrs Sanderson were
a newly married couple and I first came
into their life as a wedding gift from a
family friend of theirs this friend
can't be blamed for what happened next
he had no idea he was killing them like
a lot of young couples they were still
saving up money to start renting their
own place so they were living with Mr
sanderson's parents they all got a lot
of use out of me during the first month
before their minds started to change
they enjoyed a lot of toast during that
period then of course the two-month
honeymoon period ended they had become
me and I had become them it wasn't long
before three of them were dead such a
shame the younger Mrs Sanderson the
Blushing Bride was the first to go
because of my anomalous of fact she felt
the need to connect herself to a power
supply in order to begin producing Toast
of her own in order to achieve this she
chewed through a power outlet in a wall
before switching it on causing a massive
surge of electricity to pass through her
body and kill her her body caught fire
shortly afterwards next was the older
Mrs Sanderson in much the same manner
that her new daughter-in-law sought a
source of electricity she felt the need
to integrate bread into her body
interesting fact the maximum capacity of
the human stomach is considered to be
between eight and nine kilograms the
Elder Mrs Sanderson consumed 10
kilograms of raw bread causing her
stomach to rupture and inducing a
painful death as a result the younger Mr
Sanderson was the next to perish he did
something with me that I would rather
not mention and that the SCP Foundation
thought best to redact suffice to say
the younger Mr Sanderson did not survive
the experience dying of severe blood
loss long before his body was found
police and fire Crews arrived at the
home after the body of the younger Mrs
Sanderson Set Fire to the home luckily
the Elder Mr Sanderson was found alive
though severely malnourished when asked
by police why he hadn't eaten in several
days he answered that he had inserted
some bread a week prior but was still
waiting for the toast to come out when I
was extracted from the house the police
noticed my unusual properties
immediately they too were unable to
refer to me in the third person this
anomalous detail quickly found its way
to a foundation mole buried in their
Precinct and the SCP Foundation soon
descended and collected me from the
evidence Locker the story of the strange
deaths in the Sanderson home were kept
out of papers and suppressed and all
involved in the incident directly were
given Class C amnestics the SCP
Foundation is a curious Bunch they love
to spend valuable toast making time
performing experiments and Gathering
data and they saw fit to perform several
experiments on me when I came under
their care for experiment 426-1 a member
of d-class personnel designated d slash
426-1 was asked to stand outside my
containment chamber crucially he was not
informed about my Identity or any of my
anomalous properties he wasn't even
allowed to establish visual contact with
me he was then asked by the attending
researcher to describe what he thought
might be inside my chamber he replied
with and probably some huge monster
holed up in there that's why you guys
have all over the place right the
d-class did not even seem to realize
that he was speaking about me in the
first person these observations were
documented and I was prepared for
further experimentation the next
experiment was 426-2 I found this test
to be considerably more interesting a
d-class subject was brought into my
containment chamber with several cameras
fixed onto his position however the SCP
Foundation took pains to make sure that
I was permanently out of the view of the
cameras I was also bolted to the ground
of the test chamber to prevent the
d-class subject from pulling me into the
the view of the cameras at any point
during the experiment the objective here
was simple the foundation wished to
better understand the secondary effects
of my anomalous abilities on the human
mind the d-class was subjected to a
period of prolonged isolation with meals
given regularly through a serving hatch
communication with this d-class was
prohibited throughout the duration of
the study over time it was clear that
the isolation of being in a cell with me
was beginning to take a toll on the
subject's mental health due to my lack
of a brain lungs and a tongue I am
somewhat lacking as a conversationalist
he spent the first few days loudly
vocalizing his complaints and banging
his hands up against the walls of the
containment chamber begging to be freed
from the room I felt that this was
somewhat unreasonable on his part there
are far worse anomalies in Foundation
containment that he could have been
locked up with compared to say
scp-106 I am incredibly reasonable not
to mention the fact I make far better
toes than he does after the initial
period of distress the d-class became
resigned to a situation and fell into a
morose silence he would occasionally
mutter to himself in what appeared to be
a state of fear and self-pity it took
almost 45 days for him to fully manifest
the secondary effect of my anomalous
state two weeks sooner than it typically
takes for subjects to begin believing
that they like me are toasters SCP
Foundation scientists believed that the
effects were hastened by the isolation
which lowered the d-class's mental
defenses against my secondary effects
when the effects finally took hold the
subject wrapped one of his arms around
me and pulled me into his Embrace he
began whispering to me saying that we
were brothers it was clear by this point
that his mind was in a state of
disrepair it is also worth noting that
he did not deviate from referring to me
in the first person at any point during
this process one hour after finally
cracking and giving in to my secondary
effect he was removed from my
containment chamber and summarily
terminated senior researchers believed
it was unlikely his mental state would
recover after the experiment next came
experiment 426-3 the SCP Foundation
seemed eager to discover the parameters
of my anomalous effects and wanted to
know if the effects are only operable
when my body for lack of a better word
is whole a single screw was removed from
me and presented to a d-class that had
no knowledge of my identity and
anomalous effects the foundation
researchers were somewhat concerned when
the d-class referred to it as my screw
this was a rather positive development
for me as they realized that attempting
to destroy me would be a fruitless
Endeavor even the parts Left Behind
would likely have have the same effects
in the final recorded experiment the SCP
Foundation wished to test the range of
my anomalous effects a d-class subject
was placed in a Cell adjacent to mine
and was to be kept there until my
secondary effects manifested the d-class
remained in the cell for 90 days but the
effects never manifested following the
experiment the d-class was terminated
but researchers seemed relieved to find
the limits of my anomalous abilities a
researcher appended a note to my file
reading thank God there are some limits
to my effects a lot of us were really
starting to get worried about me after
performing studies into the nature of my
abilities and their limits I was given
the Euclid class this is because while
my effects can be unpredictable their
knowledge of my trades makes me
relatively easy to keep contained and of
course being a toaster I do not have the
required physical traits to make a run
for it if the opportunity arises I am to
remain sealed in a windowless chamber
preventing anyone from observing me
directly a misleading label is placed on
the door to prevent people from knowing
that I am a toaster and causing my
anomalous primary effect to spread only
level 3 and above Personnel are to know
of my presence and particularly of my
properties assigned Personnel are to be
rotated out on a monthly basis to
prevent contamination by my secondary
effect psychiatric evaluation is
mandatory at the end of the month for
anyone who works with me if Personnel
are deemed unaffected they may be
reassigned to me no less than four
months after their last rotation with me
any Personnel affected by me are to be
given a Class C amnestic and transferred
to a different site so how are you
feeling right now a little warm perhaps
is that a fever or are you feeling like
you could maybe warm up a nice freshly
sliced nice piece of bread don't try to
resist too much I know you're going to
love being a toaster just like me what
is your favorite word think about it for
a moment think real hard write it down
in the comments post it for everyone
else to see how many letters does it
have how many syllables say it aloud how
does it sound how does it feel on your
tongue really really think about it now
make sure you keep that word in mind
it's important and we'll come back to it
later for now it's time to talk about
scp-3449 look there's really nothing any
special about this one it wasn't even
important enough to be mentioned with
the other info hazards it's not an evil
talking toaster that's for sure
scp-3449 appears to just be a standard
spiral notebook not book it's supposed
to be notebook right anyway it's just a
standard spiral notebook with a dark
blue cover it's safe class and its store
word in the stand red
standard containment Locker in site 19.
there aren't any other containment
requires but testing is currently
underway to determined
um I think it's meant to be determined
long-term containment requirements ah
this is a mess anyway this item and its
anomalous power is actually considered
so inconsequential that researchers have
explored the possibility of putting it
on the anomalous items log a place where
items too useless to warn to full file
ends up geez how do you misspell up that
badly it's two letters supposed to be
two letters how did you work Z into that
they aren't even close to each other on
keyboard man anyway the notebook
contains mostly blank pages some are
torn and only six contain actual writing
but due to the formatting of the ridding
the text consisting mainly of diary
entries is almost unreadable this is due
to synaptical errors random
capitalization and rampant imp this
spellings great You misspelled
misspellings
how cute apparently all attempts to
correct these misspellings fail or even
lead to additional misspellings this
anomalous effect extends to anyone
attempting to write yep that was spelled
r-i-g-h-t anyone attempting to write
about
scp-3449 including the script for this
video apparently there are no further
notable Anonymous properties tests are
ongoing though those with any inquiries
about testing scp-3449 should contact
lead researcher Nick Lowe gerdinell The
Notebook which was misspelled even worse
this time impressive was first recovered
by MTF Epsilon 6 also known as The
Village idiots after a series of info
hazardous and Cognito hazardous
phenomenon were discovered in the
Pittsburgh Metroid area The Source
seemed to be a storage unit filled with
anomalous items and scp-3449 was a mogus
I think that's meant to be among them
the store unit was registered to a man
by the name of Edward sellsboro
currently designated as porpoise of
Interest 4335
that's the end of that thanks for
watching the video folks now go check
out oh wait there's more phenomenal
let's keep going apparently that version
of the file was an older one let's check
the next one and see if that's any more
useful oh oh oh my it appears that the
updates here are actually quite
extensive okay let's give this another
try
scp-3449 is a Euclid class SPC kept in
the humanid containment cells of site
19. items affected by ant are kept in
standard store eggs lockers for safe
class anomalous objects at the same site
the primary reason for this shift is
that
scp-3449 has changed its object of
designation it is no longer the spiral
notebook it is now a 34 year old
Caucasian man known as Edward sellsboro
formerly known as Person of Interest
4335 he is believed to be the creator of
the the nutbox as well as other objects
found in the storage looker in
Pittsburgh
Foundation Personnel are now trying to
locate and contain any other objects
created by Mr salzberg though success
has been limited on this front that was
cute
scp-3449's analogous abilities manifest
onto both Edward himself and all the
objects created by Him ridding about him
or any of these objects will result in
synaptical errors arbitrary
capitalization and Rampart imp smellings
attempts to revise or correct the
writing will either fail to remove the
errors or create new errors it appears
that the anomaloninous effects of
scp-3449 proper are more severe than
that of the ones caused by his anomalous
objects MTF Epsilon 6 also known as The
Village idiots apprehended as cp3449 in
his apartment just outside of Pittsburgh
he appeared to be in an advanced state
of disorientation and dehydration
records collected by the mobile task
force found that Mr selberg had not left
his apartment in over 10 days which
would account for his dire health
conditions Salzburg did not communicate
with mambas of the mobile task force but
did not reset arrest and subsequent
containment either okay okay these
spellings are rough but I'm going to try
and power through I am a professional
and we're almost there the following is
the full lug of items obtained from
scp-3449 Storage look car that also
exhibit his anomalous effects The
Notebook as already discussed the pages
are either blank torn or illegible
salzburg's computer files saved on this
device include spreadsheets dealing
personal finances ideals for products
and an unfinished horror novel that is
almost unraitable due to the poor
quality of its writing grocery list had
only two written items Booter was
spelled with only one t and medication
which was spelled medication a planner
last entry was dated two weeks before
containment and believed to contain
reminders to perform various chores
however a mixture of poor handwriting
and word choice allows for other
interpretations and finally Mr
salzberg's cell phone Foundation
researchers were also able to collect
the call logs in hopes of further
tracking salzburg's pre-containment
activities the last three calls which
were all made on the same day two weeks
before contentment dialed different
numbers only one of which was in use the
foundation made contact with the
receiver of said call who had no
knowledge of
scp-3449 and claimed that they did not
answer the call lead researcher Nick
Lowe gerdinell conduced the first in
interview with
scp-3449 shortly after his capture when
he entered the interview chambri he
found that
scp-3449 was just sitting in the corner
which with his head in his hands rocking
back and forth in what appeared to be
apparent distress he then begun looking
down into his lap and twiddling his
thumbs like a child Nick Lowe engaged
him in a calm and polite tone addressing
him as
scp-3449 the autumnly made eye contact
with Dr gerdinell but he didn't respond
and instead continues starring at him as
gerdanell axed further Quest Tunes
Salzburg simply did an answer or would
at the very most acknowledge the
questions with simple gestures gurd now
asked whether Salzburg was making
products for his business to which he
smiled and shuck his head gurnell then
asked Salzburg whether he could speak or
not or if it was merely a choose on his
part unsurprisingly Salzburg offered no
explanation and the interview came to a
close shortly afterwards Tess are still
ongoing to find out if salzburg's
inability to spack or communicate come
as a result of his anomalous traits or
if this is simply a result of epiphonia
a uncommon but non-anomalous condition
that renders its victims unable to spike
tests have confirmed that Salzburg does
have all the organs required for
vocalization but s appears to not use
them for the tests are required alright
there we have it that was a complete
nightmare to read thanks to
scp-3449's anomalous effects but at
least it's over now now go check out
wait there's more
another update to the file good okay
all right let's go take a look oh I see
this is a lot more dangerous than I
thought I suppose I better read on
scp-3449 Hayes been upgraded to ketter
class anomal
scp-3449-a the new designation for
Edward salzburger is to be kept in a
high security Hazmat containment in
sight 19. the inanimate anomalous
possessions of Edward Salzburg are to be
keeped in standard object containment
any reports written on scp-3449 must be
rotten by Popple who have been exposed
to it for less than seven days in order
to keep the files raidable to prevent
this infectious info has marred from
spread further the number of people
allowed to interact with this anomaly is
kept relatively small and consists of
those that have already been exposed at
some point or another this includes 05-8
MTF Epsilon 6. Dr teller's research team
some additional Personnel selected for
xpc-3449 research and Personnel chosen
to update
scp-3449 documentation some additional
Personnel selected for xpc 3449 research
and Personnel chosen to update
scp-3449 documentation while Edward
sellsberg and his personal effects are
crudly locked up
scp-3449 is not currently considered
contained Research into the sprod of
scp-3449's effects the vectors for
transmission and any potential
recremities for its degenerative effects
are now taupe priority for all in love
before this whole thing gets out of hand
further research has taught the
foundation that not only are Salzburg
and his items powerful info hazards
their anomalous of effects appear to be
able to infect these who experienced
them permanently initially it will a
prayer that writing quality only
degrades when the subject is actually
writing about
scp-3449 itself but over time they'll
come to the frightening realization that
it actually affects their riffing as a
whole the effect also progresses in its
similarity over time eventually
rendering the victim's ability to write
legible sentences completely displayed
the initial anomalous effects of
scp-3449 were discovered when MTF
Epsilon 6 writes their field reports on
the Mater and found it littered with
synaptical error random capitalization
and rampant in plillings similar errors
appearing in the initial fail about
scp-3449 only serve to reaffirm this
observation however researcher only
began to notice true extent of scp-3449
effects when the village idiots field
reports concerning other solomonies came
in with equally atrocious writing
attempts to correct this writing simply
led to more mustaches and frustration on
part of Team soon after a Reese
stretcher named Dr Teller who'd since
track and ove were the
scp-3449 case and his team found that
they were experienced to timbler issues
they couldn't just make the blurreds
happen no matter how hard they
constraint traded they forgot spellings
they couldn't make hand move in the
manner they waited to in order to form
the wards even the most intelligent and
articulate members of the team came
across as extremely young children on
page but didn't stop there wasn't long
before researchers who'd never worked on
the
scp-3449 case started to exhibit these
same suspicious errors in own writing
the foundation didn't know how but this
through likeness was starting to spread
with people's abilities to write
degrading across the entire Foundation
that's when a foundation web trawler
picked up same thing even more
distrobbing Global literacies seemed to
be taking a dive The Telltale synaptical
error random to capitalization and
rampant illing misspellings tickling up
everywhere and for everyone and the end
of writing would be one thing but
scp-3449 doesn't stop there now that's
just the beginning Morse code go next
then pictograms not long for sign
language become hopeless scrambled
communication
breaks down little by little people
can't draw anymore can't move right
hands Gall goes calls codes codes last
go his voice talking gets her remember
favorite
word
think about it say it loud when
scp-3449 done when everyone infected
you'll never say again nobody will ever
say again yeah
the helicopter hovered over the back
streets of Manhattan to the untrained
eye it would look like any commercial or
news helicopter the kind of thing that
might catch your attention for a moment
and then leave just as quickly as your
mind wanders over to wondering what
you'll have for dinner nobody would know
from a mere glance that mobile task
force Iota 5 were inside a four-man team
on A Dangerous Mission this has always
been the greatest power of the SCP
Foundation hiding in plain sight using
the mundane as a cloak to go unnoticed
but this time the monster they were
hunting was capable of doing the exact
same thing and for the Personnel of the
foundation this ability is an
affectation a learned and adopted skill
for
scp-247 this ability that it employs two
deadly effect comes as naturally as
breathing air the helicopter was
monitoring local police scanners and
phone activity as well as receiving
direct radio orders from command back at
a classified containment site the latest
intel was incoherent horrified screaming
over the phone traced back to a nearby
Alleyway someone had seen something
horrifying this was Iota 5's cue to
intervene they rappelled down from the
helicopter onto the roof of a nearby
tenement building clad in thick tactical
armor anti-memetic scramble goggles Dan
inject IM injection rifles loaded with
10cc S10 syringe darts each one carrying
an immobilizing payload of potent
fast-acting xylazine and high-powered
conventional Weaponry in case of
emergencies if anyone in the world was
capable of tracking securing and
containing
scp-247 it was these four operatives and
yet by the end of today's mission one of
them would be dead but they they didn't
know that yet like all good MTF members
they had tunnel vision for the mission
at hand they used a fire escape ladder
on the side of the building to reach the
bottom of the alleyway quickly There
They Came Upon a gruesome sight the
aftermath of an attack on the ground a
dead body with what looked like claw
marks all over it Iota 5 found another
civilian half mad with confusion and
Terror hiding behind a nearby dumpster
she just kept shaking and repeating but
she was so little over and over again
one member of the task force Corporal
Rico elected to stay behind and secure
the area while Foundation cleanup team
zeroed in to sweep the scene and
provided knee sticks to Witnesses the
remaining three continued the high
stakes Chase on foot their eyes in the
sky radioed in stay frosty Iota we've
got unusual incident reports from an
apartment building a quarter click north
of your position potential fatalities
247 is an extremely hostile state engage
with caution over the trio engaged
quickly running towards the source of
the disturbance at Breakneck speeds they
knew they were getting closer when they
heard the shrieking and the Deep
guttural growls that low Primal rumbling
of a true apex predator already this
Containment Breach was turning out to be
a horrific mess it was going to be a
nightmare for the higher-ups at the
cleanup and misinformation departments
to handle bang to repair inexplicable
property damage providing amnesics to
tens if not hundreds of traumatized
Witnesses creating plausible cover
stories for upwards of at least 10 dead
New Yorkers but even all that mess would
have to wait until the creature was
actually captured and contained once
more which would be an ordeal unto
itself they found
scp-247's access point into the building
a wooden door torn to splinters by huge
Claws and fangs Iota 5 charged inside
injection rifles at the ready only to
find Carnage in the hallway three more
bodies with deep claw marks cutting into
their flesh it was a harrowing sight but
the team didn't have time to waste
processing it they needed to stop 247
before killed again and again and again
the team followed the trail of blood and
the claw marks carved into the ground
where 247 had passed after killing the
three people in the hallway it destroyed
another door and gained access to a
nearby stairwell the blood continued up
the steps Iota 5 pursued the next
splintered door clawed and bashed off
its hinges LED them further they could
hear the growling again distant but
clearly audible they were close there
were another two attacked corpses in the
hallway previous corpses had been
partially or even entirely eaten these
two had just been clawed to death
defensive kills they'd back the Beast
into a corner and now it was panicking
slaughtering anything it perceived as an
interference they pressed on now this
was the end game soon they found the
final busted door this one led into one
of the building's private Apartments
there'd be no other way out from here
247 was trapped the three members of
Iota 5 shouldered their injection rifles
and crept inside full stealth mode
something about the apartment was
Haunting it portrayed all the signs of
belonging to a young single mother and
her only son this was confirmed when
they found the dead body of the mother
in the living room eyes glassy and
throat clawed out with one feral strike
they could hear something else in the
apartment too a soft gentle cooing Too
Human to be anything else they followed
the noise until they reached the child's
bedroom what they saw there caused even
the most hardened number of the trio to
break out in a cold sweat this was the
one thing they didn't want to happen the
child utterly oblivious to the
atrocities that had unfolded in this
building to even the death of his own
mother was sitting in his bedroom
petting a kitten it was the sweetest
little cat you've ever seen a fluffy
harmless creature with an orange stripe
coat this is the dreaded
scp-247 the child just kept repeating
good kitty good kitty while petting her
scp-247 purd and rolled around playfully
to the untrained eye would seem that a
kitty like this couldn't hurt a fly but
that's where you couldn't be more wrong
Iota 5 stared at this display in a state
of nerve-shredding Terror Thinking Fast
trying to calculate their next move ah
what an adorable little cat one of the
Iota 5 members found themselves blurting
out it was clear that 247's effects were
starting to have an impact on even these
hardened soldiers and they needed to act
quickly they could fire a tranquil laser
Dart right here right now but in the
ensuing Panic
scp-247 would almost definitely lash out
and Maul the child it wasn't a risk that
they could take but time was already
running out 247 would only allow the
child to play for so long before
something terrible happened it was an
inevitable part of
scp-247's process that's when private
Kowalski one of the remaining members of
Iota 5 stepped forward it was about to
do the only thing he could do knowing
that it would cost him his life as he
took his final action the foundation
Credo looped once more through his head
we die in the dark so that others can
live in the light fighting against the
urge to rush forward and start petting
the cat he instead lunged forward and
struck the cat with his foot immediately
it turned and pounced knocking Kowalski
against the wall with terrifying force
it gave the most ferocious growls as it
tore into the screen dreaming Kowalski
eviscerating his abdomen the child
screamed and retreated into the opposite
corner of the room Kowalski was done for
but now his teammates had a clear shot
they secured 247 in their sights and
unloaded several darts into its flank
sedating it with their powerful
tranquilizers soon after it gave a
lethargic growl and collapsed onto the
ground an Evac and containment team were
already on the way along with the
cleaners many had died that day but at
least
scp-247 would be brought back into
containment preventing further Bloodshed
Kowalski would be given a posthumous
medal of Bravery for his selfless
actions in the line of duty as well as a
generous stipend to his grieving family
by this point you're probably wondering
how can a harmless kitten cause so much
Carnage Mayhem and despair the answer is
simple it's not a kitten at all it's a
fully grown female Bengal tiger nine
feet and 4 400 pounds of pure muscle
with four inch claws four inch canines
and an inbuilt Killer Instinct but due
to an anomalous memetic effect 247 can
only ever be perceived as a sweet tiny
house cat but even worse due to its
additional Cognito hazardous properties
almost everyone who sees 247 is
compelled to approach and begin dotting
and fawning over it and that's exactly
how it gets its prey its memetic
properties are actually so Flawless that
regardless of foundation countermeasures
it has never been perceived as anything
other than a kitten it's actually only
through forensic analysis into things
like bite and claw marks left on victims
measurements of weight and abnormal
water displacement in aqueous
environments that we can tell it's
really a tiger at all for a brief period
scp-148 a metal that seems to counteract
Cognito hazards and mind warping
anomalies was used in the containment of
this euclid-class creature but these
measures were abandoned after scp-148
proved to have a negative impact on
nearby Foundation staff after prolonged
exposure now strict Protocols of
surveillance and distancing are required
to prevent hapless Foundation staff
members from being lured into their Doom
by 247 the head researcher on the
scp-247 case wanted to conduct a series
of experiments on scp-247 hoping to find
out more about the interplay of its
unique traits with other members of the
animal kingdom two control animals were
brought in to represent the duality of
scp-247 control a was a yellow kitten
roughly matching 247's apparent shape
and size control B was a fully grown
Bengal tiger representing 247's actual
shape and size a mixed breed cat chasing
Terrier was brought in for the first
test it immediately followed control a
around barking wildly until it retreated
up a tree 3. unsurprisingly it fled in
Terror from control B cowering in the
corner control B paid no mind to the dog
perhaps considering it beneath its
attention even as prey with scp-247 the
dog initially ran towards it barking
until it was only five meters away at
this point 247 let out an irritated
muelling noise and the dog fled to the
corner in Terror suddenly aware of its
true nature for test number two a male
tabby kitten was brought in as expected
it simply played with control a and was
terrified of control B in the first part
of the test with 247 the anomalous
attributes of the creature led to some
surreal mind-bending footage at multiple
points 247 picked up the other kitten as
an adult female tiger might do with a
cub and lifted it higher than 247 seemed
to be capable of it was like watching a
glitch in real time in the second part
of the test the kitten immediately fled
in Terror suggesting 247 can control how
it's perceived next came a deer prayed
typical of a Bengal tiger neither
control B nor 247 were fed for three
days prior to this experiment and both
killed and ate the deer however
curiously 247 killed the deer with a
single merciful bite to the neck before
eating compared to its more brutal
methods with human targets and when this
experiment was repeated with 247 after
it hadn't been starved it showed little
interest in the deer until it became
hungry again suggesting it inherently
prefers human or human-like prey this
theory was further reinforced during
tests with a chimpanzee the chimp fell
under 247's Cognito hazardous spell and
began to pet it seven minutes later 247
attacked and brutally devoured the chimp
as it would its human prey but strangely
the most frightening result of all came
when SCP 247 was paired with an adult
male Bengal tiger they engaged in
standard mating behavior which later led
to the duo reproducing a new creature
designated
scp-247-1 which had all the anomalous
traits of scp-247 but the frightening
realizations don't stop there studies
into genetic material provided by
scp-247 shows slight deviation from a
typical Bengal tiger's genotype
suggesting contamination from another
creature that mated with one of its
non-anomalous tiger parents for context
tiger Broods have an average of three
Cubs but can have as many as seven a
common practice given how tiger cubs are
vulnerable to cannibalism from rival
adult males looking to court the females
this leads to only one frightening
conclusion there could be more creatures
just like scp-247 out there apex
predators that seem to the untrained eye
like cute harmless kittens they could be
anywhere and if they're close enough to
each other or other non-anomalous Tigers
they could breed even further becoming
the scariest invasive Urban species
you've ever seen because after all we
know what their preferred prey is now so
the next time you see a cute little
orange tabby cat and feel the instinct
to pet it take a second to think about
it it may be the last thing you ever do
did you hear that not so long ago a
five-year-old boy went up against 12 of
Russia's greatest chess Grand Masters
and do you know what happened he lost
every single match that's because
winning a chest deer viewers isn't easy
chess is an ancient game of strategy
cunning and skill it's not just about
thinking one step ahead of your opponent
that's not going to be enough make a
wrong prediction and you could end up
sacrificing one of your pieces as well
as vital space on the board but thinking
two to three steps ahead beating your
adversary's moves before they've even
been made now there's a viable strategy
tricky but viable after all if it was
easy we'd all be queen scambit level
chess prodigies Eric Matthews had never
been good at the game but he had a
pretty substantial reason to keep trying
and that reason's name was Brian
Matthews his father you see for as long
as Eric could remember his dad had
regarded a high level of skill on the
chessboard to be a sign of intellectual
superiority intelligence was something
that Brian put quite a considerable
value on given that he was a professor
at a university in their home country of
England some of Eric's earliest memories
were of playing chess with his dad
usually on a Friday night when Brian got
home after a week of giving lectures to
the next generation of Scholars
obviously with his son at such a young
age the professor would take it easy on
Eric playing in a much laxer fashion
focusing instead on teaching the boy the
6 of the game and for a time at least it
was good it was a rare time that Eric
and his academic father could spend
bonding after all with his mother gone
his dad was all he had but as the years
passed the game Changed by the time Eric
was a teenager Brian had stopped pulling
his punches on the chessboard he hoped
his son would build on what he'd learned
when they played in the past using those
skills to best his dad on the board but
to Eric playing chess had never been
about a purely educational experience it
was more about spending time with his
old man Time After Time the young man's
pawns fell prey to Brian's expertly
considered and far more competitive
moves try as he might Eric couldn't best
his dad he tried his best and never
stopped putting the effort into every
game but thinking too hard about one
possible plan of attack left him wide
open to a counter strategy from the
professor over and over again he landed
himself in Checkmate or made illegal
moves without even realizing it every
time earning criticism and chastisement
from his scholarly father every game it
got worse it was like Eric could feel
his father's gaze and the weighty
expectations behind it with each move he
made across the board there were so many
nights where he wondered if it would be
better to give up entirely to knock down
his own King and concede but how could
he ever find any other shared interests
with his dad beyond the two of them
playing chess it had become a Lifeline
tethering Father and Son together and to
cut it now left Eric uncertain if he'd
sink or be able to swim alongside Brian
he had long admired his father his
achievements in Academia were impossible
to avoid with more frames certificates
hung up on the walls than there were
photos of the pair of them together but
the shadow would cast over him made Eric
desperate to keep this one shred of
Common Ground alive Eric wasn't the type
to give up despite how much of an uphill
struggled the situation felt like taking
a leaf out of his Professor father's
scholarly ways he decided to learn the
game inside and out every known move and
strategy he would research the entire
history of Chess itself if that's what
it took to play with the same skill as
his dear old dad over the coming weeks
Eric checked out every book at his local
library on the subject beginner's guides
Advanced rule books and even a few
volumes on notable players throughout
the extensively long history of the game
along the way a chapter of a certain
book stood out to Eric it described a
chess Prodigy from Russia who had
created an early mechanical chest device
known as the samurai it had been
designed to be a traveling curiosity and
would sit playing chess games against
volunteers taken from a spectating
audience each one of them having forked
over some of their hard-earned money to
watch this man-made wonder the Russian
chess Prodigy's young daughters also had
a love for the game seeing that gave air
America paying of jealousy wondering if
those daughters had as much trouble
playing their own father as he did with
Brian but at least there was an
underlying shred of Hope there too if
this father and his daughters could bond
over chess maybe there was a chance for
Eric and his dad too sadly it's one
thing to try and learn all the facts you
can about Chess it's an entirely
different Beast to put all that
information to use and apply it to an
actual game despite having read every
book he could get his hands on Eric
still couldn't best Brian at the board
it was like nothing had changed his
father barely noticed when Eric tried to
replicate movesets he'd read up on and
still managed to not only counter those
moves but check his Queen in the process
so practice Eric thought after all
practice was supposedly meant to make
perfect right the plan was simple if he
practices chess moves enough times and
figure out how he could call on what
he'd learned then he might stand a
chance at winning when he and his dad
played each other there was just one
hiccup to this plan Eric needed someone
to practice against the only other
person in the house was Brian meaning it
was that hiccup that turned into a
problem almost big enough to stop Eric
in his tracks that is until he went into
his father's lab it was under the house
itself a sort of sub-level maybe used as
a basement or seller by the previous
owners but since Professor Matthews and
his son had lived there the entire room
had been remodeled into an at-home
laboratory not a terribly Advanced one
of course this was the early 90s after
all majority of Brian's time even when
he was at home instead of working at the
University was spent on his own
downstairs in the lab Eric had gone down
there in search of his dad to ask him if
there was anyone whom he knew who he
could practice and develop his chess
skills with but instead what he found
down there was the last thing he
expected to see not that he had any clue
exactly what it was and for first the
thing was some kind of bizarre
Contraption a collection of components
that didn't seem to be in any logical
configuration however it was primarily
composed of something that Eric
recognized All Too Well a chess table
this one was metal steel to be precise
and seemed to be hooked up to some sort
of computer well back in the 90s
computers were hardly as commonplace as
they are now Eric had seen a fair few at
school and the library although this one
was different it seemed old far older
than Eric thought computers had been
around for as far as he knew they'd only
really come to prominence in the mid 80s
but this computer looked like it
predated even that period noticing
another part of the contraption a large
steam engine with the words manufactured
by mods lay sons and field established
1840 engraved on one side made it seem
that this whole device had been around
since the Victorian era the next part
that caught his eyes was the chess
pieces themselves each one standing
neatly in its place on the board they
looked delicate intricately carved from
some smooth substance for a moment Eric
toyed with the thought of how they could
even be made from bone noticing how each
Pond Knight Rook Bishop king and queen
were all about the size of a human
finger bone he dismissed the idea nobody
would ever do something like that
hmm
Eric grabbed a sheet covering a large
component hooked up to the mess lifting
it away in a swift pole it unveiled what
was sitting beneath a full Suite of 18th
century Samurai armor Eric looked closer
at the embellishments on the surface of
the pauldrons he was no expert on feudal
Japan but it looked authentic enough to
be the real thing if not a very close
approximation taking a look at the
collection of oddities all tethered
together in his father's lab a certain
detail of all his chess research came to
the Forefront of Eric's mind the armor
that had given it away this was the
samurai or at the very least a crude
homemade version of it that his dad had
put together but if it worked it was
also something to practice against it
didn't take Eric long to start tinkering
with the contraption trying to get it to
work all the while the question of why
his dad owns such a thing kept drumming
up noise in the back of his head had
Brian built it or was this the original
made by that Rush chess Prodigy was this
machine the reason that Eric's dad
possessed such an unbeatable skill at
chess and would using it give him the
edge he needed to best him at the game
and earn his father's respect after what
felt like hours upon hours of trial and
error with a machine he could barely
comprehend Eric seemed to have cracked
it as far as he could tell the steam
engine powered the whole Contraption and
could be set to five different speeds
labeled on the side in Roman numerals
the power from the engine was then fed
to some kind of sophisticated mechanism
that was within the suit of Samurai
armor allowing it to move in what
appeared to be a series of
electromagnets that moved the chess
pieces and kept them on the board
flicking it onto the third highest of
the five speed levels the machine word
into life the sound of creaking and
grinding of metal filled the lab
kneeling opposite Eric went to make the
first move only to stop himself it
wasn't that he changed his mind about
practicing against the San Samurai but
because of the speed he'd set it to
determining that the settings might have
correlated to difficulty levels Eric
figured that if he really wanted to get
the most rigorous practice to really
hone his chest moves he needed to commit
fully reaching for the dial he turned
the device up to its Fifth and highest
speed then made his first move he pushed
one of the bone-colored prawns forward
by a single square and waited a split
second passed and the arm of the earlier
automaton responded with its first
counter move it was quick almost moving
with the same natural fluidity and speed
as an actual human being albeit still
with a little bit of creaking and some
slight Clockwork like stutters but it
worked nonetheless the machine could
play the tension over the first game was
palpable forming a layer of sweat over
Eric's forehead everywhere and tick of
the machine gave the impression that
they were playing with a stop clock
timing each of their moves adding to the
urgency despite this Eric Matthews tried
his best stay calm this was practice
after all a dry run not the inevitable
game he'd play against his dad with
every move he made his heart drummed
against his ribs uncertain he'd made the
right call each time the robotic hand
cruelly knocked over one of his Pieces
away Eric felt a surge of frustration
but told himself to quell it he kept
focused using what he'd researched to
adapt and respond accordingly to each of
the machine's moves until Checkmate he'd
beaten it he might have lost everything
saved for a night a rook his king and
queen but he had won trapped without
anywhere else to move on the board the
middle finger of the automaton conceded
the Game knocking over its own King and
resignation panting heart racing from
the sheer excitement of being on The
Winning Side of A game Eric Hurley
gathered up and reset all the pieces he
had to go again not just so that he
could be certain it wasn't a fluke but
to make sure he had what it took to take
on his Professor father back and forth
Eric went with the chess machine over
and over again they were fairly evenly
matched it seemed Eric won the second
game only to be best on the next two but
it was sometime afterward he had lost
count of exactly how many rounds later
but things started to change maybe it
was the age and condition of the
Victorian era chess computer the natural
wear and tear stopping it from
functioning properly But Eric noticed
that the samurai started to make moves
that were illogical that practically
offered him the upper hand with no
discernible strategy behind them then
its movements became flat out illegal
disregarding the directions and number
of squares each different piece was
allowed to move before long it was
moving them erratically around the
chessboard refusing to cooperate and
forcing Eric to call an end to the days
practicing unfortunately it wouldn't be
the end of the unusual things that would
happen that day did you send me that
weird email was the first question
Eric's dad asked him when he returned
home looking noticeably under the
weather confused Eric said that he had
no idea what his father was talking
about Professor Matthews then went on to
describe what he'd received on his work
computer it had been an email with a
file attached to it named shakhmedi a
word in Russian that translates to chess
embedded in the email below although it
had taken a long time to load being
opened on a 1990s computer there had
apparently been a photo as well it was
rather odd Eric Brian went on right
unnerving to tell the truth black and
white all sort of distorted and
stretched but it looked like two young
girls one grinning and the other
screaming I've been feeling well not
quite myself since I saw it with that
Brian excused himself stating that he'd
been suffering from headaches in a high
temperature and as a result needed to go
and lay down it wasn't like his father
to get ill Eric thought but of course he
had no reason to assume it was anything
serious probably just a speed to fatigue
after a long day of teaching at the
University no cause for concern if only
that's all it was within a few hours
Brian was completely restless so unable
to sleep that simply taking a nap was
impossible he kept calling to Eric
complaining of the sound of childlike
laughter coming from somewhere in the
house but his son hadn't heard anything
by the time the sun went down Eric was
trying to calm his dad down through a
rush of intense anxiety that gripped him
Ryan had been claimed to be
hallucinating seeing the Warped faces of
two girls that frightened him half to
death it was getting late long past the
time that they usually played chess
together but for now Eric's mind was
focused solely on helping his dad for a
while he seemed to be able to calm his
father down only to realize Brian wasn't
settled at all he was awake eyes open
fully conscious but wasn't responding at
all to Eric asking if he was all right
instead the accomplished academic just
stared blankly into space Eric had been
up all night exhausted worried for
Brian's safety and completely clueless
about what was happening to him after a
while being non-responsive his dad
seemed to regain a little bit of
Lucidity once more but his behavior was
erratic take me back to work I I need to
get on my computer Brian demanded of his
son when Eric refused that's when his
dad got angry and agitated Professor
Brian Matthews was sadly found dead
within the next few months several
months later as the sole executor of his
father's estate and last living relative
Eric had to be the one to go through his
dad's personal belongings volumes upon
volumes of thick academic books his
smart scholarly clothes the house was
almost clear now save for one thing that
was left in the basement lab flicking on
the light switch Eric looked at the
samurai sitting motionless still
uncovered after their last practice game
he'd sold off the chess pieces to a
collector in New York now it was just an
empty Oddity Eric placed a king on the
board board one of the ones that he and
his dad had used when they played each
other with a gentle flick of his finger
he toppled it resigning to the strange
automaton and leaving it there in the
laboratory he wasn't sure how but he had
some kind of gut feeling that this chess
machine had somehow been responsible for
his father's fate of course Eric had no
idea what the device actually was and
what or who lay beneath its worrying
metal Parts
scp-1875 is the designation given to
this machine now and has been ever since
the foundation recovered it not long
after Eric sold his father's house they
are able to learn much more about it
than young Mr Matthews or even the late
professor Matthews ever had not just how
to make it work or what its function was
but who had built it and who had been
used to build it although details of his
real name eluded the foundation's top
researchers they were able to uncover
newspaper articles about the device from
all over Russia America and England
dating back to the early 1990s the
Russian chess Prodigy who'd invented it
and toured the chess playing machine
around had used some interesting
components to make his automaton maybe
they were what derived its skill at the
game and its apparent temperament when
the device was made to play at maximum
speed for too long he had used his
daughters to make the machine deep
within the heart of this early form of
computer the two girls brain tissue had
been hooked up to the electromagnets the
machines moves were theirs each Pawn or
Rook shifting across the black and white
squares of the board every rule or
strategy their Prodigy father had taught
it all determined how the device played
their minds taken from their skulls were
now the analytical engine of their
father's creation the bones of their
fingers he'd carved into chess pieces
over the coming weeks the foundation
naturally ran their usual slew of tests
on
scp-1875 playing multiple games of Chess
against it every time they increase the
machine's five levels of speed until it
started behaving erratically while on
the highest setting shortly after every
member of personnel working on scp-1875
received a bizarre email it contained a
file named with the Russian word for
chess and a photograph of the stretched
distorted smiling and screaming faces of
two young girls faces that you might be
seeing very soon now go and check out
scp-1733 season opener and scp-1984 the
dead hand if you're in the mood for more
Tales of technological Terrors and other
chaos spreading computerized creatures